Optimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
so does brought to you by headspace.
More than 80% of the people I've interviewed,
world class performers across the military,
entertainment,
sports,
and beyond all have some type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help you.
This change comes through guided meditation and headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple,
so what I recommend is that you take this practice meditation,
which is rooted in thousands of years of tradition,
supported by thousands of scientific studies and try it for 10 minutes a day for
10 days.
That's all you need to do.
You could also check out the founder Andy Puddicombe,
a Ted talk,
which has more than 5.5 million views.
His last name is p.
If you want to look that up,
but otherwise,
download the free headspace APP.
I have it on my phone and begin their take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation.
Completely free.
10 minutes a day.
That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash Tim just go to headspace.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by exo protein.
It's one of the startups that I work with.
I love what they do.
These guys are making protein bars using crickets,
protein powder,
and before you screw your face up and look disgusted,
I bet they taste better than any protein bar you've ever had before.
I devour these bars after lifting sessions.
I take them with me on the road.
The recipes were developed by a three Michelin Star Chef,
former head of r and d at the fat duck,
which was ranked the number one restaurant in the world during his tenure.
The bars are paleo friendly,
no gluten,
no grains,
no soy,
no dairy,
et cetera.
They are high in protein and flavor and extremely unique and they do not pop
your glycemic response up oddly enough,
and you can look that up on line to see some stories on that Ferran Stein,
that's the journalist who looked at it on top of all that.
They are less processed than nearly all protein bars.
You'll be able to find.
This is your chance to see what the hype is about and the founders were just on
the Forbes 30 under 30 list and they are offering a deep discount to Tim Ferriss
show listeners.
If you go to exo protein Dotcom,
forward slash Tim that's [inaudible] protein.com forward slash Tim today,
you can try a sampler pack with all of their most popular flavors for less than
10 bucks.
That's [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim and I would recommend doing it
relatively fast and that's not a bs scarcity thing.
They're startup with limited inventory and they sell out all the time.
That is what happened last time I mentioned them,
so check it out.
EXO,
protein.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
each episode is my job to deconstruct world class performers,
to tease out the lessons,
routines,
habits,
breakfasts,
favorite books,
etc. That you can use and borrow from world class performers whether they are
military strategists,
chess prodigies,
athletes,
actors,
politicians or anything and everything in between.
And this episode we have a very exciting guest,
uh,
with whom I've been spending a ton of time.
Christopher Sommer,
you can find them on Instagram and Facebook.
I highly recommend checking it out.
Gymnastic bodies is the account name is the former US national team gymnastics
coach.
He's also the founder of gymnastic bodies.com a training system that I am
currently testing the hell out of and I have no affiliation with it in so much
as I get no kind of affiliate anything,
pay out,
whatever.
I'm just fascinated by bodyweight training and reached out to coach summer to
try to finally practice gymnastics as a 38 year old and I've learned a lot.
We've been toying around with things for about six weeks now as of this
recording.
And we're doing a 90 day custom tests so I hope to have some very interesting
before and afters for you guys so we will be doing a round to followup as a
world renowned Olympic coach.
Summer is known for billing his students into some of the strongest,
most powerful athletes in the world and you got to check out his Facebook page.
He features a lot of these athletes.
It is bonkers.
During his extensive 40 year coach and career coach,
summer took meticulous notes on his training techniques,
his wins,
failures and so on so that he could translate the best elements and do a
superior exercise system for both high level end beginner athletes.
His four decades of careful observation led to the birth of gymnastic strength,
Chin.
Let's try that again.
Gymnastics,
strength training,
not vocal strength training,
some failing in that department,
otherwise known as GST.
In this episode we cover a ton of stuff and I think it's going to light up the
Internet's because everybody has a strong opinion these days,
but coach summer is very well qualified to have the opinions that he holds.
We talk about the biggest mistakes of self taught handstands.
Why recreational athletes who tried gymnastics get injured?
Most commonly we talk about the three to five exercises everyone should be
doing.
Chances are you've never heard of some of them.
We talk about mental prep for athletes who are going into big competition.
The questions you should ask a coach before sending your kid to gymnastics.
Uh,
we get into what is wrong with Yoga handstands,
Eh,
the questions or opinions that he might pose or have related to kipping pull
ups in crossfit and elsewhere.
And uh,
I asked that question because a mutual friend said,
if you want him to lose his shit,
ask about kipping we have the determination of GST,
this gymnastic strength training goals.
If you could only pick one,
what would it be and why?
Who are the best coaches he's met?
What characterizes them?
It just goes on and on and on.
I mean,
if you want to build,
say mass in the biceps,
how you can utilize straight arm work and why you must turn your hands out past
parallel.
Well,
when training the rings,
why is that important?
How does it affect muscular development in strength development?
Why do you need to fix the lats to fix the shoulders?
But it goes on and on and on.
This is a very in depth conversation.
We get into the weeds and I would just say be patient.
They're on a lot of gems here and similar to the Dominic D'agostino episode on
Ketosis and the end of cancer and so on and so forth.
We really get into some nitty gritty detail on that is why many people listen to
this podcast.
So just bear with me if you're like,
what the hell are these guys talking about?
Give it 30 seconds.
Chances are that we'll zoom back up to 30,000 feet or change topics,
so stick with it and please enjoy this very wide ranging intense conversation
with coach Christopher Sommer.
Coach,
welcome to the show.
Thanks Jen.
I am excited to finally have you on the show.
We've had so many conversations in the last month or two and I've been so
impressed with the,
the subtlety and nuance of the training that you do.
Uh,
so I've been very eager to have you on the show to explore,
uh,
all things,
gymnastics and gymnastics,
strength training related.
So thanks for making the time.
First of all,
my pleasure.
You come forward to it.
And I thought,
I thought we could,
we could start with just some definitions.
So what would you or how would you define gymnastic strength training?
Gst?
Ah,
that's a good question.
Uh,
in a nutshell,
gymnastic strength training I define as um,
high level body weight strength training.
So,
uh,
none,
none of the technical training that we do for world class performance or the
acrobatics or technical gymnastics,
just purely the strength,
joint prep and mobility components.
And one,
one example of what not to do perhaps or,
or how gymnastic strength training might differ from the aesthetics that some
people,
I'm not going to say compromise with,
but shoes we were talking about doing a pike,
I guess a Pike handstand press or holding that position.
And the example,
and I feel free to correct my recollection,
but was of how a lot of folks kick their hips way out to counterbalance instead
of doing what,
what would the gymnastic strength training version that look like?
A good example.
So what we see,
and this is kind of getting into some handstands,
some skill training,
but um,
handstand done correctly is a reflection of physical preparation that athlete
either has or does not have.
So if they lack strength,
if they lack mobility,
then of course their technical Hanson is going to lack refinement.
So though in terms of that pike can Stan,
if they lack middle trap,
if they lack lower traps string,
then they're going to try to counterbalance by really arch in the chest out,
stick in the boat,
way back behind them.
Uh,
goodness,
not even sure how to describe it like a pike in an arch at the same time.
Sorry to interrupt.
Coach just lets people who I realize I should have probably defined some terms
myself.
So Pike for people who are not familiar with this.
Uh,
the easiest way to visualize it if you don't have any background with that is
imagine you're sitting on the floor.
It's Kinda like PE class legs straight and together,
uh,
bending at the waist,
towards your toes,
forward,
bending forward towards your toes.
Uh,
and so if you were in,
imagine you're sitting down with your legs out in front of you at a just to like
hypothetically at a 90 degree angle and you put your arms up over your head.
Let's just flip you upset outs here and a hand stamp position.
That's effectively what we're talking about,
exactly what we're talking about.
And to hold that because center of mass is way out in front of the body.
Then in order to hold that,
the traps are what's responsible to keeping the back and the shoulders straight.
So if you're not strong enough,
and is it,
some people say,
well,
it's just skill training.
Well,
everything builds upon everything else.
So got Olympics coming up,
people are going to be pumped.
They're getting to see our Olympic team,
they're going to see the other monsters around the world competing on rings.
And there are,
I want to do that and they're going to jump right up.
You know,
I've got friends who are former seal team six and first thing they did is jump
up and of course they failed at early and then they come see us.
Cause it's,
it's like anything,
you know,
you don't jump right into calculus.
You learned to count and we learn a dish and we learned subtraction,
Yada Yada Yada.
Whether enough time and enough layers,
not progression.
Then we get to advanced math.
So advanced ring strain,
same deal.
And we,
I remember we were talking not too long ago about the importance of pacing when
you're dealing with connective tissue tendons and ligaments,
which is something,
uh,
I'm not per se,
I'm not particularly well known for in terms of patients and things,
but I've noticed that,
uh,
the,
at any of the guys who say do outdoor bar workout,
so of Witcher,
I'm very,
very impressive.
Physical specimens will jump up on the rings and they'll be doing,
I'm not sure what they would even call them.
They're kind of like what would be looked at as like a typewriter on the pullup
bar when you move back and forth from one arm to the other side,
decide pulled up,
I decide pull up and they were like,
I was feeling fine coach.
And then suddenly,
you know,
I tore my Bicep,
right,
tore my package and it was fine until it wasn't up.
What are some,
if you look at,
uh,
the
muscles or types of strength that most non gymnast's will not have,
even if they consider themselves reasonably athletic,
what would be on that list?
And we already mentioned one,
which is say mid and lower traps.
And of course,
I mean I,
I would like to think I came to the table with kind of hat in hand because I
recognize how hard a lot of this is.
But the more I practice it,
the more I'm astounded at how unprepared my body is for these movements.
I mean it's a,
as someone who has done a lot of pulling from the floor,
for instance,
who has,
you know,
decent deadlift,
I would like to think,
uh,
I was just astonished at how weak my mid back was.
It was just,
it blew my mind.
It was,
it was,
it was completely flabbergasted.
And what other,
what other muscles are movements do you find?
Uh,
normals just cannot perform even if they view themselves as athletic.
for the,
for the lifters,
the one that always jumps out at us is their lack on shoulder extension.
So,
um,
if I pick my,
if I'm standing upright and I lift my hands forward,
that's flection and I can go all the way up to my arms are overhead fine picking
my hands up behind me.
That would be shoulder extension.
Right?
So just to paint another picture for folks,
like if you stand up and then interlace your fingers behind your tailbone with
your arms straight and then tried to lift them up towards the ceiling,
keeping your back straight.
Uh,
so the shoulder extension and what we find,
as you know,
and a lot of what we'll get sometimes from people as well.
I don't want to be in the circus.
I don't want to be an acrobat.
I,
I'm not interested in skill training.
I want,
I want strength.
And what they don't understand is if you want to achieve world class levels of
performance,
technically that comes first from adding a solid foundation of physical
preparation,
which means correct range of motion,
right?
Good Mobility,
good connective tissue.
So shoulder extension become,
so for example,
a lot of people fail.
They can't do muscle ups because they can't do shoulder extension.
They think in their head that a muscle up his chin up,
a little bit of transition that they don't understand.
And then it dip.
What really happens as we do a pull up and we get our hands to our chin and then
the elbows pull back behind the torso behind them and there's their shoulder
extension.
If they can't do shoulder extension,
now they're stuck.
And they,
they had spent all this time working technique and doing rap and doing rap.
And what they're doing is they're treating the symptom,
not actually the problem.
Well I was,
uh,
so just as some background for folks,
the way that we connected was I at 38 finally decided enough is enough.
I've been fantasizing about trying to learn gymnastics in a structured way for
20 plus years.
Much like my postponing of getting a dog for 20 years.
It's just like why,
why did it take me so long to do this?
And
I was in Venice,
I'm going to give these folks a shout out.
So there is a crossfit gym there named to parody.
So crossfit and I just love the folks who run the gym and I would go there and
train cause they would let me use chalk and do all the things that a lot of gyms
will not allow me to do.
And uh,
I met a gent who was doing a bodyweight workout.
He's the only person doing a body weight only workout.
And he suggested that I follow a gymnastic bodies on Instagram.
And so I started following your company on Instagram and saw older,
uh,
let's just call it middle aged men,
sort of my demo as it stands right now,
uh,
who had started from scratch doing impressive things.
And I had used age as my crutch and excuse for not pulling the trigger in the
last few years.
So I reached out to rob wolf who was kind enough to introduce us.
And then,
yeah,
we've,
uh,
collaborated in this experiment that we're currently doing,
which is roughly 90 days with a handful of goals that we'll get to you.
But I want people to understand how we connected.
So I'm in the middle of training right now and it's a,
I have to say,
I feel better than I've felt,
um,
with the exception of a little bit of elbow nonsense that is,
uh,
is not from this specifically.
It's a recurring thing,
uh,
feel better than I have in,
in years.
Uh,
the going to hear just from this little bit already.
We just from the little bit that we've done and uh,
the,
the follow up question to that is,
uh,
for instance,
um,
when people are training for handstands at home,
so self taught,
what are the biggest mistakes that they make?
Well,
they won't like the answer and a,
this is a little bit of national team coach attitude coming out beat people tend
to want what they want when they want it.
And that's fine if,
if I'm looking for
mediocre to average results,
if,
if I'm looking to,
to really do best effort,
then I've got,
I've got a back shit.
Um,
and I've got to take care of my business.
And for most of the adults it's going to be,
they have severe compromises in their mobility.
Their shoulders don't work well,
their hips don't work,
their knees don't work,
their elbows are shot.
Their forums are tight from all the desk patrol.
Their calves are like piano wire from sitting all the time.
Uh,
when we won't even talk about hip flexor there scabs don't move.
Their scapula have no motion.
They can't protract,
they can't retract.
Their spine is locked in,
just a flat or a Chi Floyd's for they're hunched over,
their lower back is continually arched and they're just kind of frozen in this
position.
And then they want to try to move their body.
Now the common one that we get from people as well,
these are extreme of motion.
These are artificial ranges of motion and actually these are your natural range
of motion problem as they quit using it.
And so I just atrophied.
So we're not,
we're not doing anything special or just how we have to recreate that natural
range of motion first.
Uh,
this we've,
we've been doing,
gosh,
I don't know now,
maybe since 2006 working with the adults and uh,
the thing that just,
we keep having my nose rubbed in it over and over and over again.
Every time I think I have it down,
I find I need to take it further.
It's just the complete other lack of joint prep and mobility they come to the
table with.
And if we do,
even even your,
your own cases and excellent example,
we haven't done anything advanced yet.
We're doing all basic or doing fundamental stuff and you're already feeling
better than in years.
Well,
I think it's a lot of it has to do with two things.
If I'm trying to self diagnosed,
the first is absolutely identifying musculature and motor patterns that I simply
had not developed properly previously.
Um,
even even if I had a passing familiarity,
like the,
uh,
let me frame this in the form of a question.
So how do most people,
can you define what the hollow position as,
why it's important and how,
how do most normals do when they do a,
say a hollow body rock?
And maybe you can explain that too.
Ah,
so what,
what people,
they're going to,
most people when they think of abs,
they think lower abs.
They think upper abs,
they're not going to think about Oh,
leaks at all.
And they're not gonna think transverse abdominis at all.
So lower abs are easy.
Upper Ab,
easy.
Bleaks.
Okay.
They,
they understand the sideways.
They don't understand how obliques wrap around into the lats and to the lower
back.
Okay,
that's fine.
But transverse abdominis,
they're like,
excuse me,
did it,
was that English?
They don't have a clue.
And that's what supports the body when it's in a straight body position.
So you know for,
for example,
ab rollers were,
we don't use them in our program,
but just as an example,
ab rollers were getting a,
a bad knock that if you do an ab roller,
you're going to hurt your lower back.
Well,
yes and no.
You'll,
you'll hurt your back if you're doing it wrong if you are arched and your lower
back.
So for definitions,
if my lower back is arched,
I'm an anterior pelvic tilt.
If I'm the opposite movement and I'm kind of,
my tailbone tucked under and my lower back is flat,
that's posterior pelvic tilt,
I'll move my body's horizontal.
Then my,
uh,
back is supported when I'm posterior pelvic tilt.
If I'm arched,
it's unsupported by the Moscow's churn.
I'm hanging by the disc,
which is true for a ton of exercises that we do in terms of thing.
If I feel it in my lower back,
almost universally when I send you videos,
the feedback is more PPT posts,
posterior pelvic tilt as it should just be a mantra for,
for people who need a way to visualize this,
because I realize a lot of this is new.
So,
and coach,
feel free to interrupt at any point.
But an easy way to think about,
and remember,
anterior pelvic tilt is imagine that your,
your,
your waist is the top of a wine glass.
If you have anterior pelvic tilt to the front,
you're going to be pouring wine out the front of that glass,
basically out of your belly button.
And if you have posterior pelvic tilt,
you're talking that tailbone,
you're going to be pouring wine basically down your sacrum,
you know,
down,
down the back of your body.
It's just an easy way for me to,
to remember as that is clever.
I got to say 40 years of national team and I've never heard it described that
way.
Yeah,
it may,
it may be our go to definition.
Well that's uh,
I,
you know,
I can't do the gymnastics so I'm going to,
I'll have to stick on,
stick with the refining my definitions.
Although I am,
I'm making progress at the fundamentals and the Sui.
I'd like to talk about the assessment that we did.
So I flew out to a great gym,
awakened gymnastics in Colorado and we met up RGB master Phillip.
We only have one in the world and a awaken in Denver is our number one GB
affiliate.
They're the best at what they do.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a fantastic Jim.
And we did quite a few hours of various assessments.
If somebody wanted to try to self assess or videotape themselves to have,
say someone qualified in gymnastics,
assess them.
If you were to do an 80 20 analysis,
like which movements or exercises give you the most data?
Most banks,
most of the bang for the buck.
Okay.
Let's see.
No,
so what we went over with you,
we checked hanging leg lift,
hanging leg lift automatically is going to tell me the dynamic range of motion.
Is that right?
That's a like on a stall bar.
You don't want to be free swinging.
I'm good.
Most of them.
You know what,
whatever.
They can do it to my eye.
As soon as I see it or our staff side there,
they're going to know right away whether or not that person has adequate,
it's going to tell us your core strength and it's going to tell me hamstring
flexibility that that'll do that.
And one bridge bridge is a huge one for adults.
That's been one of our,
we have a Thoracic Bridge Corp stretch series and that's,
that's been one of our bestselling products.
That's what I'm doing this evening.
Yeah.
Notice,
notice guys,
that Tim's real happy right now.
That'll change in just a few.
Yeah.
What,
what characterizes,
this is a really important question.
What characterizes a good bridge?
And for people who are thinking of bridge,
I mean it's,
imagine you're laying on your back,
you put your,
your palms down by your sort of ears,
let's say feet flat on the ground and then you go up into an arch.
Now,
uh,
W I was extremely surprised and found it quite hilarious how bad my bridge was.
I mean terrible,
uh,
in the assessment,
but your standards.
Yes.
By what I see on a normal basis,
yours was,
yours was medium.
Medium.
It was like a d plus.
It
was like on the verge of passing.
But I realized despite all of my many years of wrestling where we did tons of
bridges,
almost all of my bridging,
it comes from bending at the low back,
right?
So my lumbar a huge issue.
So what is a good bridge?
Little background.
So the lumbar and the lower back is not designed to have a ton of movement in
it.
And Big Arch,
your thoracic spine,
your upper in your middle back.
They're designed to have a lot of movement.
They're designed to rotate.
Your lower back is not,
but when most people do their bridgework there,
they're so compromised now,
okay,
even back up a little bit more,
I'm there.
There are so compromised in range of motion,
their upper body,
because they'd been hitting the weights hard.
They've been doing just a lot of high intensity training.
Now to preface that,
there's nothing wrong with that.
There's nothing wrong with that at all.
If you weren't one of God's gifts when you were born,
you've got to do something to make up the deficit.
The problem is when they do all that weight training,
they're not doing it in balance and maintaining their mobility.
If they had,
they wouldn't have the issues that they ran into.
So if all you do is strength string,
string,
string strength and you can always tell someone who has their,
their the curl king in there,
the bench press king and they come in and they're hunched over and their elbows
don't straighten their arms don't go behind them and all they are like,
you know my shoulders are killing me most of the time what we found is yeah
their,
their shoulders are completely after up.
I agree.
But their biceps are crazy tight also and that bicep runs up through the front
of the shoulder and it's manifesting itself as a shoulder issue.
So kind of all of these come together and long story short to cause them a huge
problem being able to get into a proper bridge,
which should be all upper body,
no lower back almost at all.
But people are doing the exact opposite.
They hurt their lower back.
And I say,
man,
these,
these bridges are dangerous.
Now the bridge bridges aren't dangerous.
And doing them halfassed and wrong without vetting your sources of information,
it is dangerous.
And I found it incredibly therapeutic as someone who's had a,
basically a frozen thoracic for God knows how long,
10 years.
Sure.
When we were worried about that I remember were like,
hmm,
I wonder what through this Tim,
as the upper body mobility of a lego figure,
what are we going to do?
So the,
but just the progression of doing,
uh,
and of course people should look for visual references and,
and I'll,
I'll point them in there exactly when they're on all our courses and that's all
of them to a bunch of resources in the show notes.
But the,
can you walk through the check boxes because I know we've done this even
recently.
Uh,
the,
the concept,
I don't know why this didn't even occur to me,
but of helping to take the lower back out of the equation by elevating the feet,
elevating the fee.
Yup.
And elevating them as high as necessary.
Uh,
some,
some people are so tight that they basically start in a handstand and it is what
it is,
right?
The,
the main thing that we try to always hammer with students is they're always in a
hurry.
I've got to get it right now.
Even even our conversation,
you remember way back when it started that way and I was like,
dude,
this if you can handle it,
we need,
we need to change gears here.
We need to go slow now in order to go fast later.
If you want to be a stud later,
you have to be a Pud now I think where your words,
yeah,
that,
that sounds like a smart ass remark.
That's a good one.
I wrote that down.
I've corrupted you all your great podcast and I've corrupted you.
Uh,
so what are the other check boxes?
So let's just say they get the feel and they're like,
okay,
feed,
elevate it feet elevated to the point where they're not feeling stress on the
lower back.
Then now it'll depend on pressing strength also.
So if they're,
if they're very weak in the shoulders,
then they're going to have to start from the handset in and work their way down.
But we'll assume they've got feet elevated,
hip high or higher if necessary.
It doesn't matter a bit.
Then from there we're going to work on,
most people are going to be up there going to have bent elbows.
So we're going to work on straightening the arms no matter how close they are.
They could be wide.
These why?
Yeah,
because,
gosh,
I had one special forces guy that came to me years ago.
Uh,
tough,
tough guy,
first name mark and uh,
he had gained 80 pounds of muscle,
80 pounds a month.
Oh yeah.
He always just like,
holy moly.
And he was,
he just a beast.
But uh,
he had completely after himself up cause all he did was gaining strength without
mobility and athletically.
If I'm not,
unless,
unless my sport is just purely lifting,
unless I'm a power lifter on less,
I'm an Olympic lifter.
Okay.
Then then maximal strength is not my sole criteria for being successful.
In fact,
usually the strongest athletes in the weight room are not the best athletes on
the field of play.
And in fact,
I,
I don't know a single exception and there may be one there somewhere that
someone can share with us and letting me know.
But I've,
I've been around the world.
You,
I won't say as many people as you know,
but in 40 years of worldclass gymnastics,
I've,
I've met a ton of people.
I've never seen an exception.
Uh,
he couldn't even hang on a bar anymore without,
with his arms straight,
without hitting his head.
Why you think your shoulders are tight?
Pull mark.
And he was like,
coach,
what,
what can you do for me?
For once I was at a loss for words,
which is rare for me.
I as I,
you know,
I,
I think you're screwed dude.
I can fix this one.
It's a,
what did you do with him when the bridge was he just stuck?
We couldn't even desk.
This was hanging on a bar.
We couldn't even get number there.
That was,
it was impossible.
Uh,
what we would do with someone like that.
And Mark,
so you're,
you're a more,
it's all guys.
Just,
just to give the audience some,
some feedback.
I went into Tim's assessment
expecting medium,
medium,
and Tim.
Tim was much more mobile,
a much more athletic,
much more well prepared than I had anticipated.
So we,
I had spent a lot of time putting a custom program together for Tim that because
he did so well in his assessment,
I had to throw the whole damn thing away and started over from scratch because
basically you're [inaudible] was too,
he was too advanced for what we had assumed.
He was coming to the table with,
uh,
someone who is crazy compromised.
Uh,
we're going to have to sneak up on it,
Oregon,
where I have to get in there and we're going to have to first do pec minor when
now this is not pec minor.
We got to get in there and we got to work on the BICEP tendon.
Like I get the bicep tendon gone and we got to work on forearms,
get forearms loose,
we've got to break the SCAP.
So there's some motion there.
We have to do all of that.
And it's,
it's not high intensity work,
but it's gotta be done.
And as you heard Tim say,
the body thrives on it.
It's,
it's like a tonic for the body.
The body feels so much better because it's what the body's supposed to do.
And it's,
it's,
it's not,
what's the word I want?
It's not a lot of people don't care for it cause it's not the high intensity,
sexy work,
but it's that fundamental work that makes the high intensity sexy work possible
later.
Well,
bloodily possible.
That's safer.
Uh,
that's,
that's a good point.
Cause we had,
I think one of the questions that people asked,
you know,
I date,
uh,
I think one of the Tim asked for questions on Twitter and,
um,
you know,
what would you like me to ask coach?
Some are,
and some of the people came back with,
you know,
I know someone who's a gymnast and they're just beat the shit.
And My,
my answer to that is simple.
They weren't my athlete,
they weren't my athlete.
We don't train through pain.
Uh,
as a national team coach for a long time,
uh,
physical preparation was always our number one priority.
We built the physical structure first because if you think about it,
it's kind of silly.
We,
and we see this a lot with people who are getting into weightlifting there,
crossfitters there,
Olympic lifting and they're,
they're enthusiastic,
they're excited and they want to get that weight on the bar and they're,
they're trying to build technique with a flawed range of motion,
which of course gives them FDIC technique and it doesn't work.
And then they get hurt.
Or You,
you hear someone,
Oh,
I changed my shoe and I blew my knee.
Seriously,
your knee is that tight that because your heel,
if you're new,
she was a fraction of an inch higher or a slightly different angle that your
need blue words.
And in our training program,
we need to call everything.
You need an optimal surplus.
Range of mobility,
range of motion.
You need optimal surplus strength.
You need the optimal surplus of stability.
You need what you need to perform and a little extra for when things go south.
Not if things go south when things go south.
And if you're just riding the edge of what you're capable of,
it's and they hope,
oh,
nothing will go wrong.
I open other than a little wrong,
oh,
it is going to go wrong.
It's absolutely going to go wrong.
And so you,
you prepare the body for that ahead of time.
So when it does go wrong,
it's like,
oh,
that didn't hurt.
I didn't get nothing.
Nothing's injured.
Moving on.
Next turn.
Well,
one of the questions that you've asked me multiple times when we've been going
over different workouts,
and I would mention for instance,
uh,
I felt it in my Bicep,
I felt an extreme stretch in my bicep.
So for instance,
there's a movement that we've been calling a German hang.
A lot of people would call it skin the cat.
Uh,
perhaps,
uh,
very similar where you would hold on to say a bar or rings in this case.
And I'm just,
I'm going to get to simplify this of course,
but talking up,
going back in between the rings and then hanging down,
um,
with my,
with as little of a,
a pike at the hips as possible.
Right.
Nice.
Flat back,
nice straight hips.
Exactly.
And uh,
sort of palms facing towards the ground.
And I was saying I really felt an incredible stretch in my biceps more than in
the shoulders.
And your question would be,
and this is applied to different body parts,
where did you feel that in the Bicep,
this is getting back to the not training through pain comment and you,
can you describe why that would have loved to the whole,
the middle of your,
like if it's in the middle,
I don't really care.
Um,
in same for like the ABS.
Like we can smash those all day long.
If it's at the attachment points though,
then I want to know about it or we're going to dial it back.
Yeah.
So why is that
real quick?
So most people,
I'm going to sneak around to it.
So most people when they,
when they do their training,
they,
uh,
meaning well meaning well,
and I'm not,
I'm not slamming anyone by any means and they only reason that we know this and
are able to share is because all these years I've been doing this,
I made the same f and mistakes that they make.
We just survived my stupidity and learn how to do better.
The store it story of my life.
A story of all of our lives,
right?
I used to tell my athletes there,
there are stupid gymnast and there are old gymnast,
but there are no old stupid gymnast cause they're all dead.
But most people,
most beginners that they want to base all their training off muscular fatigue,
which is a problem.
It's problematic because muscle tissue regenerates about every 90 days,
about every 90 days,
you know,
from,
from end to end.
All,
all the cells,
everything's done in 90 days.
Okay,
that's,
well that's fine.
But connective tissue takes 200 to 210 days.
So we have a huge gap.
So if I get in and just saying,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not a big fan of beginner's training to failure simply because of their
structure isn't mature enough yet to handle it safely.
And by mature I simply mean enough productive,
well structured hours under their belt and you know,
it has nothing to do in new ranges of motion,
right.
If they've just really,
if there's joints,
you know,
if it's,
if it's a muscle belly for like you said,
if we're doing core,
you know what,
I will beat your core down all day long and I'm not worried about it at bay
because it's just muscular fatigue.
But as soon as we get joints involved,
everything changes and it's actually really easy for people to verify cause they
ain't think back over all the injuries they've had over their training career
in,
on their athletic career,
playing around with the kid in the backyard.
The vast majority of those injuries are all joint related.
I'll almost always is.
It's extremely rare for someone to have a muscle belly injury.
It just,
it just doesn't happen yet.
Their training,
especially in the beginning,
is all skewed just towards muscular develop and not connective tissue
development.
And that's,
that's where they get into trouble.
So when they come to us,
the first thing we like is for them to spend.
And it's,
is it going to be boring?
It is,
you know,
200,
10 days.
We're talking six,
seven months of dial it back guys,
dial it back.
I think that the,
it's important to emphasize too that dialing it back doesn't mean it means that
you're not rushing,
but it doesn't mean that you,
it doesn't mean you won't experience a lot of progress.
If that's fair to say.
I mean,
I think that's crazy.
Say,
and you,
you found that yourself.
But what happens is some of them we run into this.
Maybe you have also as we get some people who are addicted to the rush there,
they're addicted to the adrenaline rush.
They're addicted to lay in there,
in a pile of sweat.
Uh,
you know,
they want to do the sweat angels,
they want to crawl out of the gym.
And the problem with that is if you're a world class athlete,
you can't do that.
Cause I have to be back in the gym the next day and train again.
I can't afford a destroy myself or the special operations guys we work with.
You know,
we've,
we've gotta be able to do both.
They've got to be operational and increase their performance through their
training,
but they have to go hand in hand.
And so it's only in beginners that we see that,
uh,
they,
they think somehow they can cheat time and it can't be done.
I mean,
connective tissues Gunna take 200 to 210 days.
There's no supplement.
You can't paint yourself blue.
You can't dance under the moon.
There's,
there's nothing you can do to speed that up.
It's going to take what it takes.
And so we work as hard as we can within those parameters.
If there's joint pain,
we shut it down.
It's like you,
your elbows,
a good example.
Years ago,
pushing too hard now that,
that,
oh,
if we tweaked that elbow a little too much,
it flares up on Ya,
we'll repair it.
It's going to take time,
but it takes much longer to repair it than it does to avoid it in the first
place.
Yeah,
for sure.
And uh,
it just a couple of of notes and then I'm going to swing back to the,
the diagnostics,
you know,
how people can,
can assess.
But another conversation that,
that uh,
you know,
topic that came up,
I think I'm sure I brought it up in,
uh,
at dinner once was the use of anabolics or anytime growth agents and the,
the point that you've made,
which makes perfect sense is that would just increase the likelihood of having
connected tissue problems and gymnast because,
uh,
the muscular strength and growth will outpace the development of and the
adaptation of the tissues.
Uh,
I'd come completely went backfire,
huge backfire because we like our r s w a lot of our power come where we'd like
to get where students make their,
their greatest gains in strength has,
did,
enabled to do dynamic plyometric work and straight on ring strength.
Those are your two biggest bangs for the buck and what we have learned the hard
way.
That's different than main difference between working with young developmental
athletes and full grown adults is the order in which we need to present the
material we have to do.
As a young,
a young athlete,
I,
I can do all physical components at once.
I can do plyometric,
I can do straight arm,
I can do their mobility bent arm,
it doesn't matter a bit.
I can do it all at one time.
But an adult who's now fragile from years of making a living right,
sitting at a desk,
uh,
day in,
day out.
So they get a little older,
kids get bigger levels of activities,
drop,
drop and they're compromised.
So we'd got,
we have to build these things in a different order.
We have to first go rebuild mobility,
then we have to rebuild core Rico,
I'm talking not just avs but it'll bleaks and lower back.
Uh,
most adults,
a lot of their lower back pain isn't lower back related.
It's sill bleak related.
And um,
we,
we have to go in and we have to correct that.
Then we can worry about regular strength.
Once those things are done,
then we can get to the moneymaker,
which is their dynamic strength.
But with an adult,
especially a strong adult who's been athletically inactive,
so they've been doing strength training but not out moving,
doing sports,
being active,
you know,
outside of their conditioning or let's say for example,
all they're doing is squats and they're very linear and the path of their knee
and there's no meniscus work.
There's no MCL work,
there's no ACL work.
Then they go outside,
they play a little softball here at all the time.
Yeah.
When I was playing softball,
I blew my knee going around first base.
Really?
How many kids blow a knee running around first base?
Well that's,
I mean the supplemental knee exercises that look Wacky as hell when you first
look at them that you've had
me do,
and maybe we can,
we can show some of this to two people in the show notes.
I'm sure even in the span of three or four weeks,
I've seen a huge difference in knee stability improvement because I haven't ever
done,
I haven't ever performed these types of targeted movements before.
And going back to the diagnostics,
so we talked to about the bridge,
we talked about the hanging leg lifts,
uh,
what,
are there any other movement?
Shoulder,
shoulder extension will be huge,
so sure.
Extension would be sitting on the floor,
say
has sitting in that pike that you described earlier.
Uh,
hands touching behind them and then without letting the hands move,
trying to scoot the but as far forward away from the hands as they could.
And so that's a meeting and they just,
that one movement right there,
it's kind of,
let us see.
It's going to show me their scapular health.
Can they protrack and they retract and it's going to tell me how tight their Pec
minor is.
It's going to tell me how tight their bicep is and it's going to tell me how
tight their brachy Alice down by the elbow is.
Oh,
the Brachy Alice?
Yes.
Your favorite.
And my good friend.
The brachialis,
the and also just the,
and this relates to kind of daily living.
A lot of people who have back pain,
myself included quite a few years ago.
If you're wondering if you have a tight pec minor,
you can just Google Pec minor figured out where it is,
but basically think right under the clavicle,
get a Lacrosse ball and uh,
you know,
go on the wall and try to roll out your Pec minor with a Lacrosse Ball.
And if it's,
if you have back pain,
you don't always fix that back pain by just focusing on the location of that
pain a once a good point and you start addressing the Pec minor.
And a lot of that stuff just alleviate is,
is,
is alleviated and I want to throw one thing out there just for people who might
be interested in that.
And,
and that is,
I think part of the reason I seemed or was better prepared for the assessment
then I would have been otherwise,
is that I started doing really just one thing,
one type of new exercise,
which was compression strength training in that pipe position.
And did that for just baby,
uh,
two times per week,
prior to doing the assessment as I was traveling and for people who are
wondering what this is like,
if you really want to feel humbled,
uh,
as I did.
So I was in,
I was traveling,
I was in Columbia and very close friend of mine,
uh,
almost got to PR professional rugby in New Zealand.
He's a beast.
I mean athletically,
extremely strong,
extremely fast.
Uh,
I mean he,
he's,
he's always going to be one of the top performers in the gym when he walks into
a weight room.
And,
uh,
he saw me doing pike pulses and so I'll explain what this is folks,
because he was Kinda laughing at me and he's like,
what kind of Jane Fonda Bullshit are you doing here?
You know,
and I love that name.
And I said,
all right,
I like it.
All right,
big guy.
You're so used to just tough guy.
Let's see you do these.
So for those people who were interested in,
so you're sitting in this,
this seated pike position we're talking about,
right?
So you're sitting on your ass on the floor,
uh,
the upper body perpendicular with the floor and your legs out straight in front
of you and point your toes kind of tense your quads to push the back of your
knees into the floor.
Then reach forward and stretch forward as far as you can.
Get your fingers out on either side of your legs as far out as you can.
And then just try to lift your heels off the ground,
keeping your legs completely straight and just pulse it up and down.
Uh,
I got a three to four inches.
Maybe if you can manage that and just do,
try to do 30 of those.
And My,
my buddy could not lift his heels off the ground and just fell over laughing.
He's like,
yeah,
okay.
Those are hard.
But that compression,
it's,
if you think about the range of motion than most people train for core,
uh,
they're doing sit ups or maybe they're doing hanging leg lifts up to like an l
sit,
right?
So they're,
their legs are getting up to kind of parallel height.
Well that last 90 degrees and especially the last like 45 degrees where you're
bringing your thighs towards your chest is so hard.
I mean,
I had zero strength there,
uh,
prior to doing just a few weeks of this stuff,
which just,
it just amazed me.
Um,
and for those people also were talking about the transverse abdominous coach.
Feel free to veto this,
but I think it's also nicknamed the corset muscle if you're trying to think of
what they might look like is,
it wraps around the abdomen.
So if you can,
if you cough a lot or laugh a lot and get really,
really sore,
it's very frequently,
often,
or it's engaging that transverse.
Um,
but let me ask you,
so you mentioned crossfit.
You mentioned a couple of things he knew drenched in sweat,
doing the snow,
not snow angels,
but a sweat angels.
What are your feelings about,
uh,
kipping movements like kipping pull ups
had open that can of worms.
Well,
I was asking a mutual friend,
I won't name him and I said,
what should I talk to coach summer about?
And he said,
kipping pull ups,
he'll lose his shit.
So I said,
okay,
I got it.
We started,
I was the original gymnastics guy for crossfit and way back in the early two
thousands then ended up leaving.
I was,
I was there before there was the first crossfit affiliate when all there was,
was classmen working out of that little gem in Santa Cruz,
uh,
left.
Just because you know,
to,
to do gos t right.
Like anything,
you know,
a dichotomy that I always find curious with people,
especially the cross fitters is they will be so on point with dissecting
everything they do in terms of their Olympic lifting.
You know,
my pool is here,
my era,
my knee was the quarter inch this way,
diamond.
They,
they're just methodical and they don't bring,
and I shouldn't say just just crossfitters,
but then they other people,
they don't bring that same degree of attention to detail to their bodyweight
work.
So want one is supposed to be meticulous and one is somehow just supposed to be
thrown together and yet they expect the same quality results.
So if we,
if we look back
back in the day,
crossfit,
you know,
they're lifting was,
was nothing by national standards.
Now they get people who are qualifying to go to nationals fast forward all those
years in terms of their gym,
massive strength training.
And they're not even remotely close.
They don't match a national team.
They don't match a state level athlete who let alone a national level,
let alone an international level there.
They're not even in the same ballpark.
And part of the issue is because
the kipping pull ups were,
we're a huge big deal.
It was a money maker.
You know,
man,
I'll,
I'll be straight out of piss some people off,
but it was a money maker as advertising for a program they could bring someone
in and uh,
who's never been able to do a pull up,
have them hold their gen by the bar and uh,
let them fall,
hit the bottom of that movement,
bounce back to the top and the person's eyes light up and they're like,
you know,
this is the best effing thing ever.
I've never done a pull of my entire life.
All my God,
Oh my God.
And they're pumped and they're pumped.
What they didn't realize is that this person has compromised basic strength and
compromise shoulder flection.
They don't,
they don't have mobility in their shoulder,
so they're hitting the bottom of that movement with multiples of body weight.
So they weren't strong enough to do a regular pullup.
So now we're going to drop them on connective tissue with multiples of body
weight that's gotta go somewhere.
So it's going to force that shoulder to open further than it can handle.
And I'm going to bounce off that connected tissue like a trampoline back to the
top of the bar,
and then to make,
to pour salt on the wound.
Now I'm going to do a shitload of reps at the same time.
I'm just,
I'm just going to crank on it.
And they were getting people who were coming in and you know,
cross well there's,
there's,
there's no proof.
There's auto de,
you know,
bullshit bullshit you got,
you guys can live in a dream world all you want.
It was,
it was blowing people up.
And now the good thing though,
and to their credit,
you know,
it took time.
There was a denial.
No it has nothing to do with it.
But uh,
now we're seeing our recommendation of,
you know,
what guys,
we got to start getting some basic strength built first,
some basic mobility and then at that time kipping pull ups.
Yeah,
absolutely.
There's nothing wrong and that they're healthy.
They're good to do on a healthy shoulder joint with a good foundation of basic
strength.
But it'd be Ginter doing kipping pull ups.
Really that's,
that's insanity.
That's,
that's just pouring gasoline on a fire.
So kipping then is the finishing edition.
It is not the starting and a little bit we,
we would never,
you know,
we were,
we started working with adults.
So our first,
we do all around the world,
you know,
we spend,
we spend a lot of time doing hands on and our very first one we did,
I don't know,
2007 or so.
And we've got all these people who've got all these bees here and they're
strong.
And I tried to do my entry level plyometric work on some floor work with them
and the stronger the athlete,
the faster they went down.
Knees,
lower back,
ankles on baby stuff,
baby stuff.
I,
we're not talking anything hard.
We're talking about standing in place and with knees straight,
being able to bounce down the floor using just your calves.
No Way.
Their,
their tissues couldn't take it.
They hadn't,
they hadn't done anything like it or we had 15 minutes on the schedule.
For example,
how bad mobility was.
We had 15 minutes on the schedule to stretch.
Nothing hard,
nothing intricate,
nothing intense,
just an easy basic stretch.
Get on,
loosened up for the day.
That stretch took an hour and a half to complete and I was,
oh man,
it was an hour and a half,
10.
It was an hour and a half.
There were bodies lying everywhere.
It was like I was in Vietnam or a longer filming,
filming a war movie and I,
I turned,
I turned to my staff.
I'm like,
what the fuck am I supposed to do now?
They failed warmup.
They failed warm up.
No,
it fair.
It is.
This stuff is really you,
you,
you would look at it and just like my friend is like,
what is this Jane Fonda Bullshit?
And I'm like,
hey man,
why don't you try this for 10 minutes?
It is really taxing.
I mean I remember doing one of the stretching routines,
which I'll note I think is,
is might be of interest to people is I'm hitting each once per week.
So there's one that is [inaudible] split focus safari hamstring focus.
There's one that is bridge focus to another that is a middle split.
I'll add doctor and middle split focus inside of the thigh.
And the point that you make is doing this twice a week will not double your
progress.
It,
we'll cut it in half.
So you're only really hitting each of these once per week.
I mean there are different daily limber protocols,
but I remember doing at the very beginning of one of these workouts,
uh,
I believe it was and it was absolutely the uh,
the front split workout.
A shit ton for me.
A shit ton of,
of Ah,
calf raises with a different number.
You Moan in about like different foot placements.
It's like,
okay,
180 calf raises later of different variations.
I was like,
okay,
and I'm only three minutes into this an hour long straight sequence.
Uh,
but,
and I know we're bouncing all over the place because I want to give people kind
of a buffet sampling of,
of how this training differs.
But one of the reasons I respect the programming that you put together and the
nuance that you bring to this is that the observation then is,
and correct me if I'm,
or you can elaborate on this if I'm missing something,
but that a lot of the hamstring issues
or limitations that people perceive our,
at least in part due to lower leg absolutely issues,
including the huge amount of,
Huh.
Yeah.
Including the Achilles.
So you,
you,
uh,
in this,
in this particular progression,
in the beginning you're hitting,
you're stretching the urine gorging and then stretching the,
the insertion point basically around the heel and then again at the knee and
working your way up to the hamstrings.
And,
um,
there's a,
uh,
an athlete has been on the podcast,
a Amelia Boone,
one of the most successful,
uh,
obstacle course racers in the world.
And in,
she's basically point out the same thing.
And she said,
yeah,
you can take someone who's really inflexible in their hamstrings,
have them roll out their feet with sale lacrosse ball or something like that.
And all of a sudden they gain two inches in there to set with the hamstrings.
Uh,
because it's,
it's all connected,
you know,
we,
we found by accident so that we never intended this and it,
we just,
we're very methodic.
So part,
part of what maybe helps people to understand the layers of complexity though,
that I approached training with is that for years my,
my bread and butter was to produce best athletes in the country.
That that was my job.
In order to have a job,
I had to produce some of the best athletes in the world and we,
we had to do it from scratch.
And so that it becomes an issue of one,
an injured in athlete is no good to United States.
My Dad,
doesn't matter how talented has,
how strong he is,
if he can't go out on the floor with USA on his chest,
we,
we can't not win a medal with him.
So he's got to be healthy.
And then the second caveat that goes with that is that
okay,
we,
we have to,
so where I have,
I have to describe it correctly.
All right,
we're trying to find a way to make the best better.
Is He,
these are,
these athletes are already the best on the planet and you're going head to head
with other athletes who are the best.
So then how do you find a way to make something which is almost already perfect,
even closer to perfect.
And if you do what everybody else is doing right,
without kind of going out into the jungle,
if you will,
into Indian country and learning new things,
then you can't get a leg up on your competitors though the way knowledge off we
go.
We have PhDs who come through on this and,
and we,
we always give them major shit,
major shit because the way people think the world works is that they do their
research,
they write about it,
they publish it,
we learn about it,
and we implement it with our athletes that need,
that is not how the way the world works.
The way it really works is you've got high level worldclass coaches who are
super bright,
decades of experience.
You know,
just my last senior athlete alone,
I had 16,000 hours into training,
Alan,
16,000 hours spread over 12 years.
What does Alan's last power
power.
So yeah,
you guys got to celebrate Allen.
He uh,
oh,
you just a one national NCAA championships again,
major blowout by the largest margin in NCA history as of this recording very
recently.
Yeah.
That was just a,
this uh,
goodness.
The weekend of the 15th.
So I think we're scheduled here to come out sometime in May,
but yeah,
very,
very big deal.
But,
uh,
you know,
to,
to go back to the other.
So we're looking for looking for an edge.
And so we don't know why some things work.
We just know it works.
And I started getting notes from therapists around the world because there are,
for example,
therapists are taught that they should have a neutral spine.
You should have a neutral spine.
And I was getting people from around the world and they were writing me.
But athletically,
I'm sorry,
I'll be direct,
but neutral spine athletically is the biggest load of horse shit I've ever heard
in my life.
It's,
you can't run with neutral spine.
You can't throw with neutral spine.
You can't climb with neutral's fine.
I can't swim.
I can't do anything with a neutral spine except lay in a box,
Doug in a hole and they get ready to bury me.
I mean that's,
that's the only thing I can do it.
There's nothing athletically I can do with a neutral spine.
So we know just automatically to produce athletes.
We're not going to do a neutral spine because torso wise there's only two
movements.
I can go from an arch snap to a hall or I couldn't be hauling and snap back to
extension to the arch.
Those are the only two movements the torsos capable of athletically.
Everything else has a variation off that we can add rotation with some throws
and some this and that.
But that's,
that's all there is.
So we spend a lot of time building power for that and these therapists around
the world started taking,
are really gentle introductory work and they'd train it on themselves first.
And I'm like,
you know,
just real similar what you said to him.
You know,
I feel better than I have in years coach.
I feel better in years and this is completely different from what I was taught
in school.
Well let's say absurd,
but maybe,
maybe we could use an example that we've discussed before,
which was a new movement for me,
which is the Jefferson curl.
And uh,
yeah,
there's,
there are having some fun with that.
So we look at Jefferson curl right now.
So it wasn't that many years ago that if you squat below parallel,
you were,
it was heresy.
It was heresy.
If you want,
if you went below parallel,
the knees,
the knees couldn't possibly adapt to it,
you're just going to blow your knees.
Your,
your kneecaps were going to just pop off.
The front of our eyes can be shrapnel knee shrapnel and now,
yeah,
but everybody accepts now that you know what,
there is nothing wrong with the body being exposed to it's natural range of
motion.
Now do you have to build it up gradually?
I saw,
obviously you do,
but Jefferson curl falls into that.
So Gosh,
how do we explain Jefferson Crow?
We're going to give it a,
I can give it a shot.
Yeah,
you'll be better.
Good.
This would be a good exam review for me anyway.
So Jefferson curl
is a gradually rounded,
stiff legged deadlift.
That's the simplest way to visualize it.
So if you're looking at an athlete from the side doing a Jefferson curl,
they will,
they will most likely be standing on a box,
uh,
holding on to an Olympic barbell right in front of their hips,
slash,
legs.
So it's just like the,
the very top of a dead lift position.
But when they start the descent and it's elevated so that when you have plates
on and whatnot,
there's room for it.
But when,
when they come down,
they're going to tuck their chin and then vertebra by Vertebra round their back
down all the way into the bottom position where the objective would be,
or one of the objectives would be to get basically your wrists to the front of
your toes.
Or at least in a perfect world if you're advanced enough.
Yeah.
In a perfect world.
And of course doing this very gradually with supervised,
uh,
attention from somebody who knows what they're doing and then reversing that.
And again,
going from this sort of a,
a vertebra by vertebra rounding up until you end up in that top position and
then repeating,
uh,
is that a fair description?
Fair description?
Yeah,
the,
the easiest.
Just,
just think of it as a string of pearls and we're just curling one parole at a
time.
We'd been,
we'd been having some fun with that one.
So we,
we have done Jefferson Cross,
I don't know,
12,
15 years now,
uh,
expected standard,
his body weight for us.
A note to people listening,
do not try this with bodyweight right out of the gate.
Don't.
So for example,
one of our senior students in,
um,
in Australia,
uh,
in his training,
physical therapists has his own clinic doing really well.
And um,
he tried it with just the,
the empty bar,
you know,
the 20 kilo bars first trashed,
then he dropped all the way down to I think a kilo or two,
right,
which is completely fine.
And what we'll talk about why in just a sec.
And then he'd built up.
And last time I checked with mark over the course of on,
and I'm,
I'm forgetting there's too many students,
but around 12 to 18 months he'd dealt out to either three quarter body weight or
maybe up to full body weight.
Now,
and a back feels better than it ever has.
But the key there is people gotta understand is that this was a gradual process
over 12 to 18 months.
It wasn't just go.
Now we get,
we've got a very good,
I'll throw Quinn out.
Uh,
I'm going to butcher Quinn's last name.
Quinn's a phd and physical therapy.
Quinn.
He not does some really good work.
And uh,
how do you spell being last name?
Oh,
you're going,
you had to ask me that.
We can get it for the show notes.
Yeah,
we'll,
we'll get it for the show.
Uh,
we,
we chat a lot on Facebook in that and a queen likes to stir the pot,
if you will.
Your Nostra up some shit.
And he's experimented with Jefferson.
Carl himself for,
I think going in about three
or four years now now and feels wonderful and he'll toss it out.
And so one of the things that will always be come up is,
you know,
the,
the Miguel experiments where they would take a connective tissue from a pig
cadaver and put it under such and such amount of strain.
And if we put it in this position with this much load in snaps,
okay.
And everyone runs around in,
the sky is falling,
the sky is falling.
Oh my God.
Don't,
don't bend your spine,
stay neutral.
What everyone kind of missed the big elephant in the room was the pig was
fucking dead,
the tissue was dead.
It can't adapt.
It's dead.
It's no longer living.
And it wasn't exposed to very gradual loads so that there could be progressive
adaptation,
which is what our bodies are really good at.
So they kind of overlooked all that.
So if I take this completely unprepared tissue and I do this to it,
it'll break.
So some very interesting discussions right now on it.
I've obviously,
everyone's fine,
you know,
we've,
we've got athletes doing great adults who are doing wonderful and the,
the physical therapist will come around simply because it's healthy.
Now they've got to understand,
and other people who are listening should understand also is that our weighted
mobility work needs to be approached with a different mentality,
a different level of intensity.
Then conditioning work because connective tissue has one 10th the metabolic rate
of muscular tissue.
So it heals,
it heals slower to adapt sore.
So you have to kind of come to the table with a very patient attitude or,
or as I consider myself like I'm,
I'm extremely impatient naturally,
but I've learned order to get what I want and to go where I want to go.
I've had to learn to be patiently impatient and if I give into the urge,
then I get hurt.
Athletes get hurt,
we fall apart and we,
you know,
nationals or Olympic trials are every four years nationals or once a year and
you don't get another nationals,
you don't get another Olympic trials.
If you blow it,
you've got to be on point that day.
So it teaches us and our,
and our environment was actually a blessing because it's very much a practical,
it's very much results oriented there.
There's no room for opinion,
I think.
I feel,
I prefer it's,
it works.
If it doesn't work,
it produces results.
It doesn't produce results.
You are the best in the country.
You aren't the best in the country.
I mean it's very clear.
It's very clear and it can't be argued with.
And now that was actually something when we segwayed into a kind of the fitness
world,
if you will,
where a you come out of national team and that and everyone knows who the studs
are.
In the fitness world though,
everyone's proclaiming their,
the stud,
the national champion and there's,
there's nothing to support it,
there's no results.
There's,
there's no great athletes,
there's no great abilities that have been generated.
There's just the marketing and that,
that was hard to wrap my head around cause a national team that doesn't exist
and you can't go to the Olympics and the guy who talks the loudest gets the
metal.
It didn't have the loudest voice.
I'm champion.
I think that's national politics right now.
Oh wait,
no,
nevermind.
Different Times.
Different pod.
I did want to ask you how your visits to the White House but I figured it will
save that one for another time.
Yeah.
Tim,
Tim went to the White House last week guy.
So I'll,
I'll pick his brain for you later.
Uh,
so I,
I interrupted.
But yeah,
you get to the fitness world.
And I mean another,
another one of the differences that you pointed out for me,
which I really liked,
was that in the fitness world it's,
it's exercise and diet,
whereas in your world it's always been eaten,
trained,
right?
Shrank.
Yeah.
He eat and train because if what the people are trying to do,
and we,
we,
and I'll throw a little,
a little blurb in here.
We,
we have an outstanding nutrition program.
Uh,
the guy who wrote it,
former seal team six,
when he started buds back in the day,
he was like one 41 45 and then Jeff got all the way up to two 20,
just shy of two 25 solid muscle in his waist was the same size as 20 was thin
and he looked like two vikings,
two,
two shoulders on top of his bio.
He came walking out was like,
what the fuck?
It had been a couple of years.
What the Hell did you do?
And uh,
it's these,
it's these basic nutritional concepts that we teach.
But what we tried to do with the,
with adults is they're trying to,
they're trying to stay ahead of a bad diet through exercise or trying to outrun
a bad diet and it can't be done.
It can't be done.
And then what happens is if they somehow find this,
this crazy combination of a massive amounts of cardio and they can kind of keep
their weight in check a little bit and then they stopped that cardio,
they immediately start gaining weight,
weight gain,
weight loss,
all of that should be separate from your conditioning.
You know,
you've got to get your nutrition dialed in.
If your nutrition's dialed in,
your body's going to find its natural healthy weight that it's going to operate
at.
Now,
if you're,
if you want to be that giant muscle guy and that's not your phenotype,
which is your body type,
you know what?
It's tough shit.
Deal with it.
You know it's not going to change.
You're not going to change your phenotype.
You're not going to change your body's genetic expression game.
That being said,
right,
you can maximize what you,
what's your potential as well?
We hammer through door students as you're not responsible for the hand of cards
you were dealt,
you're responsible for maxing out what you were given.
No.
So who knows what your strengths will be.
Maybe you'll be more endurance.
Maybe you're going to carry easy muscle mass.
Maybe you're a Max Strength Guy,
maybe you're very skill oriented.
It doesn't matter.
Maybe you're very explosive,
but whatever it is,
you know,
make the most it.
So
on that point,
uh,
and then I want to come back to,
I want to ask you about,
I think it's,
I wrote this down during our assessment,
Tony Fay quote,
no routines and quote.
That's all I wrote down.
So that's a cue for a story,
I believe that you told me that we'll come back to,
does that make any sense or is that just like a cryptic 3:00 AM note that I
wrote to myself?
I don't know,
but,
uh,
the guys stay away from the wine did and never,
never,
uh,
in Vino Veritas we'll get back to that.
But the,
uh,
the,
Oh,
I know.
I kind of know what it is.
I think,
I think I can actually queue it up.
The basics.
Uh,
yeah,
we're going to come back to that one second.
The question I wanted to ask first is one that came up a lot from listeners of
this podcast,
which was,
and I'm going to create sort of a a composite of these questions,
but like if,
if someone is 35 years old,
let's just say former athlete does basic gym work,
diet is okay,
not terrible.
Uh,
they feel reasonably athletic but they're not competing in anything.
Certainly should have never done any gymnastics.
What would,
what would good goals be for such a person and what would bad goals be baby at
the same time?
Well,
I'm bat without question.
Bad goal would be for them to jump right into a kind of full body weight,
a straight arm strength.
For example,
a back lever,
which doesn't require a ton of strength,
but they love to do it because it looks so cool.
It's kind of like their first thing they can do that,
you know,
wow,
look at me.
The problem is,
is that it puts them in extreme load while in shoulder extension.
So let me,
can I paint a picture for people?
So back lever just to,
just to create the image and coach carpet from wrong.
Imagine you're laying on your stomach,
on the floor,
arms by your sides,
and then you turn your hands palm down so that your thumbs are pointing out away
from your body.
And then you lift your arms off the ground as high as possible with your arms
straight and then place a bar in your hands and then lift your body off the
ground off the ground and kind of hold yourself there.
That'll they're holding somebody would be horizontal.
Yup.
And what they don't realize is that when the shoulders are in shoulder extension
like that is that the biceps are under maximum stretch.
So it's nothing,
it's not a problem to do with being strong enough on the bicep is,
is to loading.
They're going to tear a bicep.
So we,
for a young adult now,
not a problem at all.
And,
uh,
we went through,
you know,
we,
we get some,
uh,
and we're,
we're lucky now.
We have a lot of people who use our material but some of us,
some of our material and I'll coach you're,
you're too conservative coach.
It's,
it's a new world coach.
We don't have time.
I had someone who was 21 or 23 ones.
Coach,
I don't have time to take my,
I'm already 23.
Okay.
All right.
I,
I think you're misreading this.
But they want to jump right into their strength training and they do well but
they don't do the mobility work.
So it wasn't last year.
I think it was a year before.
I think maybe the street work out community,
five of their top guys around the world snapped biceps and the,
these are crazy strong guys,
right?
I mean we've seen them.
These guys are beasts.
They're doing one arm chins are doing this and that and they,
and they all snapped him on back labor stuff cause they're,
the mobility wasn't,
was an inline.
Now we all know when you're young you can get away with a lot of stupid shit.
Cause the body heals so fast,
you know,
he luckily right are,
I certainly wouldn't have survived being 21 if it wasn't that the case,
but as an adult,
all right,
the structure is mature now and I think,
I think maybe a better way to look at it is people think I'm getting older,
ligaments are breaking down,
tendons are breaking down,
joints are getting brittle,
and actually that's not the case because if we go back in time when you were a
little guy,
when I was a little guy,
when all listeners were a little guy,
we ran around like mad men,
right?
It wasn't,
oh today I'm going to ride my bike three miles it was sun was up,
go jump on my bike and I'm gone all day and I'm running and jumping and climbing
and we're just,
we're just being crazy little guys.
Then we had,
so we had this huge matrix of activity that the body is used to.
Then we hit high school and for most people that's our first exposure to
structured athletic training.
Okay.
And the body does well with it.
Now the mistake is thinking that the body did well solely because of that
structured athletic training.
What they're overlooking is all that activity,
that matrix of activity that occurred for those years prior to that.
Then if they're a high enough level athlete,
structured training,
my continue into college,
graduate time to get a job.
All right,
I'm still,
you know,
I'm young,
right?
Hormones are pumping.
I'm going to go to work and then I'm going to go play basketball with the guys
in the unions are going to hit the gym,
this and that.
That goes good for a couple of years.
Right?
I'm getting vibe,
having fun.
Weekends,
weekends are full.
Then you meet the Qt,
right?
You meet the love of your life.
You get married suddenly.
I can't go play basketball every night now.
Okay,
so we do this and that and a little at a time.
Our levels of physical activity outside of conditioning,
her dropping down and they're dropping down a lot.
Then kids come,
right.
Well there is another huge chunk of time gone.
Then before you know it,
you're 30 you're 35 you haven't been doing hitting the gym very often.
There's certainly no time for just playful activity or doing sports or this or
that on a regular basis for most people,
right?
And they spend most of the time hunched over that desk and now the body wants to
be healthy.
It wants to be healthy.
That's the you're,
you're a prime example.
We get,
we feed it the right movements in the dosages and it blooms and blossoms is like
weeding and watering the garden,
right?
The body wants to be healthy,
but we have to do it in the right dosage.
And so for example,
those street worker guys,
they hurt themselves because it was the wrong dosage.
They want it to go too hard too soon without the mobility.
So for an adult to come back around answering that question along way 35 year
old,
very first thing we gotta do,
we've got to fix joints.
We,
we've,
we've got to repair joints.
We've got to get that range of motion back.
If you were to look at all of the adults that you've dealt with,
let's just say 35 year olds are then if you had to pick,
and of course this does not cover all the bases,
but if you had to pick say three to five movements or exercises or stretches for
addressing the most common deficiencies,
like getting this joints back into play,
what would you,
what would some of your selections,
so just just for joint joint,
I think,
I think we'd put Jefferson Curl at top of the list is Jefferson crawls and began
to let us,
it's gonna cause remember we have,
we have multiple sections of the spine,
right?
We've got the cervical,
thoracic and lumbar.
That's going to come through also into glutes.
That's going to go down into our hamstrings.
That's going to hit our calves.
It's going to hit our Achilles as well.
So far for one,
that's a lot of bang for your buck,
for one exercise.
Even if that was all you did,
Ryan and you just did Jefferson crow,
a lot of aches and pains are going to go away because of that.
Uh,
next fund west tough.
It's always,
it's always hard to boil it down,
boil it down.
We took care of Pike,
we've got,
we've got to get extension,
we've got to get some thoracic extension.
I,
I'd throw elevated bridge in there if arm strength was sufficient to handle it.
If,
if not,
we can scale it down to a,
some weighted work with some bars or some,
some barbells,
either some Dow with a plate.
Uh,
we've got to get shoulder extension in there because what happens a lot,
a lot of the conditioning we're exposed to is all front delt,
heavy.
Right?
Right.
It's all,
it's all anterior delp and the pecks get tight.
The interior delts are getting tight and we start pulling our own shoulders for
it.
We create our own impingement,
you know,
and it doesn't matter.
You know,
so I'll do more exercises,
I'll do more exercises.
We'll know you're,
you're just making it worse.
What the problem is is there is not balanced in the shoulder joint,
right?
There's no,
there's no retraction and it's easy to tell what is their posture look like?
What,
what do we see with everyone now?
We've got that,
what are they even have a term now?
Texting neck.
Is that just a kind of that that turtle forward distended forwards,
the Wally power down look and you know the scary thing there.
And again we have some pts who use our stuff around the world,
a lot of success and they're the ones who come in and educate us for,
we'll say,
you know,
we've noticed this and they can,
they tell us,
they teach us well to the limit can right because we're not professionals but to
the limits weekend they started teaching us the mechanics of what is really
going on.
So we have a very good student,
uh,
Wesley 10 runs,
one of our affiliates,
he's a fulltime osteopath in the UK,
runs another one of our GB affiliates forma GST and a Wesley's the one who
taught me that,
you know,
there,
there's a point coach or if you abuse the body it's not going to come back.
And so for example,
you see some older adults who are extremely hunched forward,
neck,
distended,
forward,
Chin up cause they're trying to see where they're going and it's not that they
have bad posture and they could fix it,
it's that they can't fix it because the vertebrae are or rectangle.
And if you spend after spending years of hunched forward like that,
it compresses the front edges of that rectangle until it becomes a trap as oid.
Right.
And that doesn't come back once.
Once that happens,
it's done,
it's over,
it's done.
Same thing happens with the muscle bellies.
So people who get frozen shoulder impingements and this that is,
if you're not using the muscle belly,
the body doesn't want to support it because muscle tissues expensive and buy
expensive.
The body looks at it,
it's expensive to feed is expensive to maintain.
So you can't your for example,
your body isn't a painting.
You can't get to a certain degree of muscle mass mobility,
athletic ability,
endurance,
whatever you want to say and then just stop and have it continue me to exist
like a painting you did right.
The,
it has to be maintained because if you're not using it,
it costs too much resources for the body to continue to keep it.
So it's going to start breaking it down.
And that's why you get a few days right.
And then you start losing strength and you start losing mobility.
You start losing when,
uh,
easiest physical attribute to build endurance.
Simple,
super simple.
Endurance is what endurance is.
Simply strength repeated over and over at a lower load.
No big deal.
That's,
that's a six to an eight week process.
Simple.
No problems at all.
Mobility is going to take some time.
What's,
what's the easiest one to fix?
Muscular strength.
Okay.
Nope,
no problem at all.
So for,
it's super important then that we,
we use that muscle mass cause if it's not being used,
you're not only gonna lose the size of the muscle mass,
the body's going to start doing deposits of college and on it and it's going to
start shrinking that muscle belly on the traps.
For example,
going back to those older adults we discussed and it's gonna,
it's gonna Shrink until a lot of it is connective tissue.
On the edges.
Now what people need to realize,
and they don't,
is that when they see an adult who's hurting,
right?
They're older,
they're shuffling,
they can't pick their knees up,
their hips are frozen,
they're hunched over,
their next displaced they,
that way when
they were younger,
this is all the result of inactivity and poor progressions in their exercises
and it didn't have to be.
And then they need to date.
Next step of connecting is that if it happened to that guy or that woman,
it can sure as hell happened to me also if I go down the same road that they
went down.
So returning to the shoulder extension because I noticed in our assessment that
I had terrible shoulder extension and I had kind of accepted it and written it
off with stupid reasons.
Like,
well,
you know,
I've done too much dead lifting,
add too much huge slabs of muscle in my back.
I can't do shoulder extension.
Total Horse Shit.
I mean,
especially notices must those huge,
massive slabs of muscle,
the imaginary lats syndrome that I have.
And,
uh,
I mean that was just blown to smithereens when I met.
Uh,
let me make sure I get his name correct as Paul Watson,
is that right?
Oh yeah.
Big Deal in New York City who's gigantic and extremely flexible.
So as soon as I hung out with him I was like,
okay,
can let people know Paul is why we say six feet to 30.
I mean,
and just in four,
he's about 40,
I want to say and just probably walked around at 6% body fat and can do,
you can do a flat chest to ground pancake.
No problem.
Can Do dislocates with a weighted dowel or a barbell.
It with all different types of grips,
which I can't do at all even though I'm making progress.
Uh,
the,
the shoulder extension,
what is your preferred way to work on shoulder extension?
What does,
is it the sitting down arms behind you scooting the hips forward?
Is there something else that you would add to that mix?
We
hafting sneak up on now on a little bit.
So sometimes we can't even work shoulder extension at first if the elbows are
deconditioned.
So if Brachialis just inside the elbow is weak,
if the insertion of the bicep tendon is weak,
then when the arm is extended as they stretch,
there might be some discomfort.
So if that's the case,
we have to give that time to adapt.
So he noticed that's one of the questions that I ask is your,
how has your break,
how's it feel?
How's your bicep feel?
How's your elbow feel?
Cause we never push through pain.
I mean,
you can,
but that's,
have you noticed that um,
the guys who push through pain,
right?
They've got a shelf life of somewhere between two and four years and then the
body is so beat up and so painful and so chronically injured that it's just
easier to be a fat slob sitting on the couch and had at least my pain drop than
to try to continue pushing through and being a stud.
I,
it's,
it's so common and it's also unnecessary.
Uh,
for example,
and I don't get this one,
I don't get this one a lot.
I'll bring it cause where there's a lot of people,
and don't get me wrong,
I really like weightlifting.
I think the Olympic lifting is uh,
there's a lot going for it.
I think the way that it is approached here in the states is not as efficient as
it's approached in China for example,
or in Russia.
So for example in both of them before there's any weight at at,
at all,
they they build complete mobility throughout the body.
They can straddle their legs,
chest on the floor,
sit with legs together,
Pike,
they've got bridge,
they have all these basic mobility,
ankle flexibility and mobility.
We talked about this as it related to huge and especially exactly you watch
cloak off to be every logo and work should watch this guy.
She got some videos.
God,
he is such a beast.
But what they also need to do is not just watch the weight he's putting up,
right?
They need to watch his warmup in the training hall and look at how amazingly
flexible and mobile he is.
Now what's important to understand is that a world class level,
right?
At a world class level,
resources are limited.
Energy you have for training is limited.
The amount of time you have for training is limited.
The amount of time you have for recovery is limited,
right?
You have to maximize these things cause you're going,
it's one thing to be the best stud in the town.
It's another thing to be best stud in the state.
Now the one in region,
number one in the country,
completely different animal to be the best in the entire world,
to be the best at what you do.
How to billions of people were talking slivers of difference between the very
top guys.
So with all those restrictions and all those parameters in place,
if the best in the world are stretching their ass off in order to get strong,
why aren't you
agreed and not you,
not you personally put me on the spot,
coach?
No.
Now you as an all of us as an all of us,
right?
And what'll happen is the people just kind of get blinders on.
They want to watch the technical,
they want to watch progressions,
what do you do for this and that.
And then they'll blow off the mobility work that they do early.
Not realizing that the mobility work was the gold nugget they were looking for.
They just didn't brush the dirt off in order to see that it was gold underneath.
They just thought,
oh it's just another rock.
Who Cares?
No it was the gold that was the suite and they missed it.
So if we're looking at,
again this,
this 35 year old former athlete maybe never was super competitive but he has
kept in decent shape,
maybe does some form of exercise two or three times a week in terms of a
understanding that the mobility and working with Jay Curl,
elevator,
bridge,
shoulder,
et Cetera,
et Cetera is going to be,
those are going to be ingredients in the recipe,
in their possession to gymnast of some type.
What would be not not,
not even gymnast.
I would say a little human being functional human being.
Right.
Cause if you don't cause I'm,
we don't train,
I'd like to point out people,
we don't train
gymnast,
we do gymnastic strength training.
Right.
But there,
I don't have,
I just got off the phone with our Olympic coast today,
Kevin Magicka.
Right.
We had a great conversation,
but guys,
regardless of how good you are,
a rope climbs and plans and this and that.
I wouldn't hold my breath that Kevin's getting ready to give you a call and say
please come and be on our team this year.
And I saw,
I saw your rope climbs and you are kick ass.
You are the one for us where we got a uniform waiting here for you.
We're a department for Rio in July,
man,
be ready.
Pack your bag is not going to happen guys.
So I think that's correct.
You know,
athletes,
functional human being covers it all.
So let me,
let me just jump to the uh,
the punchline question,
which is let's say we look at a,
if I wanted to give someone a stretch goal to inspire them to train
consistently,
right?
So the mobility might not be enough,
but if I wanted it to give them a,
a,
a light at the end of the tunnel.
So I'm like,
I know this shoulder extension stuff is going to be very unpleasant.
Maybe not super exciting,
but this is the objective.
This is why this is what you might be able to do in three,
six,
nine,
12 months from now.
Right.
The,
the back liver we've talked about is not necessarily a good goal because you
might think you have the strength and perhaps you do,
but you don't want them.
They'll definitely have this strike calls almost without question,
right?
But they don't have the mobility.
So snap goes the BICEP,
nasty surprise waiting in that box.
What would be a good gymnastic strength training goal to have?
Uh,
or goals and as just as context for people who are wondering,
you know,
the after trying to do my best to survey the landscape and figure out what might
not be the stupidest goals I wanted to,
you know,
nothing is as the best goals,
but I decided,
okay,
well press strict press handstand,
which we can define in a second seems like a good one.
And it just seems like a sweet thing to be able to do.
And then front lever and then lever straddle.
Planche then straddle planche.
Exactly.
So,
uh,
we,
we can,
we can talk about what each of those are.
But would it,
would the press handstand,
for instance,
be something that incorporates the strength of the mobility and all these
pieces?
If you had to pick one,
you had to pick one.
That would be the one,
that'd be the one.
Okay.
So let's,
do you want your line,
cause it's,
it's gonna,
it's gonna have all strength,
all mobility,
balance,
agility,
everything rolled into one movement.
How do you want to take a stab at,
uh,
at describing what that looks?
What does it,
what does a,
what does a perfect press handstand look like in your perfect press handstand?
So I'm just trying to keep it simple,
right?
Ben Dover,
hands on the ground by your toes and they can be put your palms on the floor so
they're just in front of your toes.
Shoulder width,
leg,
straight leg straight.
And now if they needed to,
Ben,
we could what we're talking about perfect world,
right?
And then so hands on the floor,
shoulders directly over the hands.
And then no jumping,
using just the middle back,
just the traps because every,
everyone thinks traps,
traps,
anything traps just for shrugging.
While your traps are huge muscle,
very huge muscle.
And they don't just lie in the top of your shoulders or in the middle of your
back and down towards your lower back as well are giant muscle and they're
capable of a huge amount of power.
And when you fix those,
right,
a lot of shoulder pain goes away.
A lot of lower back pain goes away.
But to go back to our other hands on the floor,
shoulders over the hands,
using that middle back,
those traps,
pull the hips up on top of the shoulder,
maintain that flat back position.
Then we continue on with lower back finishing the legs up to the handstand.
And so a couple of things that make this particularly challenging.
Uh,
so one,
obviously you need to have the flexibility in the hamstrings and everyone,
the mobility,
you have to have the compression strength.
Like we were talking about doing those,
those murderous,
uh,
embarrassing pike pulses,
which look like they should be easy.
And they are not,
uh,
you know,
bringing your legs basically to your chest in that lasts like 10 to 12 inch
range,
really challenging.
Um,
and then the,
I think where you see a lot of people online do this incorrectly,
at least from the standpoint of having the objective of gymnastic strength
training,
right?
There are all sorts of ways you can cheat with this stuff to make it
biomechanical easier.
But if we're trying to do it strictly,
uh,
can be in why,
why do it?
And maybe this is a nice thing to throw in because people say,
well,
it's just a matter.
It's personal tastes coach.
It's personal taste.
You,
you do it this way because you prefer this form.
Now we do it a particular way because this is what builds the most strength
that's transferable to other activities.
For example,
Nessel I'll continue.
So who are,
who have all by pissed off so far?
Dad pissed off crossfitters.
I don't know how I'm going to
piss off yoga right now.
So I once had,
and I like Yoga,
don't get me wrong,
but they're,
their approach to handstand is flawed.
They want a to go bone on bone,
so they want to have their shoulders a depressed,
so they're bone on bone.
They want to have pipe shoulders.
So shoulder shoulders can elevate.
So if I'm,
if I'm standing up right and I elevate my shoulders,
that would be like me shrugging my shoulders to my ear and then doing the
opposite as the other direction.
While when we do a handstand,
it's,
and if I describe it this way,
it's gonna make sense,
right?
I want muscle and connective tissue to be doing the work.
I don't want bone grinding on bone.
That's,
that's not a recipe for longevity.
It's not going to work.
Okay?
But the easy one is as they'll say,
well,
there's,
there's a yoga handstand and there's a gymnastics handstand,
and my answer that as well,
you're almost right.
There's a handstand and there's a fucked up gymnastics,
handstand,
low.
Those are the only two there are in here.
Here's how we evaluated a gymnastics handstand,
right?
Done with Nice,
flat back,
Nice.
And all,
all being a smart ass aside,
right?
We're going to look at it just from a purely practical viewpoint which one leads
somewhere,
so if I do a yoga type pants and what that arch and the flex shoulders,
I'm not going any farther and that I can work on duration.
I can do some other things but I'm not going any further.
I do the gymnastics hand sand where it's flat now I have nice range of motion in
the shoulders.
I have strength through the middle,
back through the traps her I'd,
I've got good core strength.
I've got good compression strength now I can move on to good press,
handstand work.
Why?
What?
We want to get stronger.
That in turn allows me to go on.
If I'm in a mood and I want to do more,
I can go into more advanced one arm handstand were pure wedding work.
All,
all those things are all results of a proper nice straight line handstand that
you can't do with.
The flawed approach is is it's not aesthetics.
It's being practical because we don't do anything in gymnastics.
Right?
That's just purely aesthetics.
Why?
Why do we do things a certain way?
It lets us generate more power.
Why do we want more power?
Let's us get more air,
lets us do more.
Flips lets us do more.
Twists lets us do harder things on rings,
which means more points,
which means more gold medals.
And his,
let me,
let me throw out a couple of observations and you can correct me if this is
wrong,
but like one of them,
an example of something that people might think is f as theoretics and it
there's an aesthetic appeal but it's a side effect and not the reasoning behind
it would be a strong point in the toes,
right?
A strong plot on the legs.
See good.
So you see a lot of people doing handstands and I was guilty of this,
uh,
certainly.
And they have kind of a,
what I heard what one acrobat called Tofu feet.
They're like,
they're not fully dorsiflex to like,
they're not pulling the toes back to the knees,
which I think looks terrible.
So pretty common in yoga,
but they don't have that and they don't have a strong point.
And so they're there.
They're at the very least,
their quads and their adductors are really fully engaged,
loose.
They're loose.
And so they're,
they're,
they're leaking energy and all sorts of directions.
And it makes,
I liked that leaking energy.
Yeah.
It makes a very good description and it makes,
I think I probably stole it from Pavel Tsatsouline,
but the,
the,
uh,
this is a good buddy.
I follows a good friend of mine.
I like Paulo hobbles.
Paul was great and the,
and they're all,
and when,
what is the consequence?
The consequence,
there are consequences,
one of which is you're wasting energy so you're not going to be able to train as
efficiently.
Number two is you're not going to have the,
you're not going to develop the proper balance and alignment because you're
going to be flopping all over the place and having to correct more so than you
should.
And,
um,
so that just,
that pointing has a huge impact
on your ability to train the hand stance like us.
Really strong point.
And,
uh,
the,
the other point I wanted to make is,
uh,
because I've,
I've of course in the,
in the attempt to try to work on this in the past,
which failed and I've made a ton of progress in the last few months,
but when doing it solo,
I would watch videos online and of course not all videos are created equal.
And you had see and preaching to the choir on that and you would,
and you would see people doing a press handstand,
but they would,
they would plant really hard.
Right?
So you would,
in other words,
you'd see people,
they put their hands flat on the ground in front of their toes and then they
shoot their head really far forward to their shoulders,
travel.
If you were to drop a plumb line,
like a string with a way to the end from their shoulders,
it would hit the floor,
say like eight inches in front of their branches in front.
Sure,
exactly.
And then they go up into the handstand and they have this arch in the back and
maybe their feet are pointing straight up.
And what does that look like?
It looks a lot like what was the gold standard in sort of muscle beach,
Venice or Santa Monica,
like 19 circa 1960 40 1950 [inaudible] 1940 [inaudible] 1950s but that's going
to place a lot more structural strain on the spine.
So then if the,
what is the proper version look like?
I mean roughly,
right?
You're,
you're,
you're years or roughly in between your shoulder blades.
Your in between your arms.
Yeah.
In between your arms fully,
uh,
shoulder,
shoulders extended up or not extended.
What am I looking for here?
Pressing,
pressing down through the ground and keeping the hand the shoulders directly on
top of the hands.
Yeah.
And,
and for,
for people who want to just do a little experiment,
obviously goods do it safely.
But I was blown away the first time that someone showed this to me.
If you do a normal,
say kickup to handstand on the wall,
just the way that everybody does it,
right.
So you're,
you're,
you're kind of flipping up and you end up looking away from the wall and there
are million ways to do well.
Let's see you do that.
And then instead of doing it the way you've always done it,
you see before you put your hands on the ground,
you start with your arms overhead in the position that you want to assume on the
ground and shrug your shoulders up as high as possible.
Trying to get your deltoids to the size of your ears,
maintain that position and then go up.
And the stability is just a world of difference.
I mean,
it's night,
nine day.
It's a completely different movement.
Uh,
the,
uh,
all right,
I have to ask this because a million people asked,
since we're on a roll here,
we've already checked off yoga.
Uh,
that's true.
And I have to come back guys.
I like everything else about yoga except your handstands.
So only a small amount of hate mail for the hands down.
Uh,
and,
uh,
some of the coaches,
and it doesn't have to be in gymnastics,
but some of the sea,
but certainly could be some of the coaches who have impressed you the most.
And I,
I took down in between like my bouts of hand shaking and like accidentally
getting chocked in my mouth during the assessment.
And like what,
when I could bend
my arms then do something.
I took these cryptic notes,
I wrote down one name,
which was Alexander world champion,
male and female.
Does that ring any bells?
So,
you know,
I've been extremely,
extremely fortunate in my career.
I have,
uh,
just a multitude of friends who are world and Olympic champions,
world and Olympic team members,
uh,
world and Olympic coaches and
for all,
for a long time.
And I just kind of,
cause if that's your environment day in,
day out and just kind of becomes your norm.
Right?
And then after a while you kind of stop and think.
Like one day I was,
I was at a competition and I was visiting with some friends of mine and I came
back and,
uh,
my,
my oldest daughter was maybe around 12 at the time and,
uh,
she was like,
oh my God,
do you know,
you know who you were talking to dad?
And I said,
well,
yes sweetie.
I know they're my friends who says that that was the Olympic champion and that
was the world champion.
So,
yeah,
I know big.
I know.
She's just like,
oh my good God.
Well,
Dimitri billows or Jeff is a good friend of mine and Dimitri is,
um,
one worlds in 83 at 16 years old,
16 years old,
just unbelievable.
Then he won again in [inaudible] 87.
What p what a lot of people don't know is in between there.
Dimitri,
obviously Russian,
uh,
Dimitri had a car accident and broke his left lower leg between the knee and the
ankle and 42 places.
Oh,
42 places a.
So basically,
you know,
as powder,
it's powder and uh,
he's,
you know,
they put a man,
he's unconscious,
he's on the table and he's,
he's covered up and they're getting ready to remove his,
uh,
his lower leg.
They're going to,
you know,
taking it off and,
uh,
the surgeon pulls the towel down the sheet down because he's prepped for
surgery.
I mean,
he's out and he sees it's Dimitri.
Now this is Russia right in the early eighties.
So know it's not,
it's not warm friendly Russia.
And,
uh,
the doctor,
he,
the doctor immediate like,
Holy Shit,
I am not cutting his leg off because of the surgeon who takes Dimitri bellows.
Chevs leg off is probably going to lose his hands shortly thereafter.
Also national hero.
So they,
they save his leg and Dimitri comes back from it and,
uh,
wins worlds and 87,
goes 88 Olympics.
Does Greg Metal,
gold metals.
Uh,
well,
Dimitri was a,
I was lucky enough we're at different training camps in that.
Dimitri was my roommate and you know,
Russians are Russians,
right?
It takes,
it takes a long time for them to warm up to you.
So it took,
I don't know how many years,
but we started getting along real well after some years and he started sharing
some stuff and I'm like,
you know,
Dimitri,
because of his leg is trashed.
It was like a strategy.
She had eight.
And I said,
Dimitri,
you know how,
how the hell dude?
He says,
God only last for a few seconds.
I can do anything for a few seconds.
I said,
I don't know dude.
Well,
so this is great.
Right?
So He's,
you know,
a legend in gymnastics.
If we get together with a room full of world and Olympic champions who are
Russian,
they will all differ to Dimitri.
He's,
he's that big a legend.
And this is in a room full of massive egos,
bandy.
These guys.
Yeah,
there's,
there's no shortage of confidence here.
And if Dimitris in the room,
they treat Dimitrios and it's,
it's a very,
very cool thing to see.
Well,
we go forward.
Ah,
Gosh,
I'm gonna forget my name.
Is it out?
Not Alexander,
while Alexandra and the reason that God had houses like my Alzheimer's,
my Alzheimer's is kicking up anyway,
we had um,
a world champion from the Russian on the women's side who a won worlds and
Dimitris coach Alexander was responsible for training both of them.
So Alexandra is the only one in history who produced a war,
a male world champion and a female world champion.
He's the only one.
And Alexander Right now is down coach in the a Brazilian team.
What is El Genders?
Is that his first or last name?
Slash I always screw up all the Russian pronunciations.
All my Russian friends are going to laugh because they're totally used to me
butchering this,
but it's like Alexander Alexander and off or something.
Got One of those and I'm like Sandra north of,
I know with my Russian friends,
I just say Alexander and everybody knows who I mean,
so I don't have to embarrass myself.
What,
what makes him,
what do you think allowed him,
made him,
makes him him.
Yeah,
exactly.
What makes them different?
What makes him him is the ability.
So it starts with
depth of knowledge to have enough depth of knowledge that you can look in an
athlete and plan what you need to be doing four years from now,
eight years from now,
and then reverse engineer all of it to today.
All the training cycles,
the strength,
the deloads,
uh,
it was from Dimitri that I for,
so back in 83,
Dimitri was the only gem and I think today probably one of the only ones who
every fourth week was a deload week.
Why?
To give the body a chance to recover.
Now there's a lot of people who talk to you load,
but way back then,
right?
The training,
if you'd visit with Dimitri ride,
it's always Chris it sits is mathematics.
It's all mathematics we do to them.
You take these correct pieces,
would you be like doing the correct numbers that creates your equation if you
put the equation together correctly and then you solve it,
there's your answer and your answer is the physical preparation at the end in a
successful competition.
So Alexander has great,
great at knowing we're going to just be consistent over this training block.
So,
you know,
an Olympic cycle is four years long.
So we're getting ready to finish this to Olympics.
Right.
And then the next cycle starts.
So it could take,
for example,
to get someone to
75,
80% of their genetic capacity with a good,
with a good coach,
a good world class coach is going to take three to four years.
It's gonna take three to four years just to let the body grow,
adapt.
Do you think that's also true for 30 flight training and adult?
I do.
Okay,
great.
I do.
Uh,
now that's a healthy adult.
That's a healthy adult.
So if they're severely compromised and I saw that,
you know,
to get through our whole,
our whole curriculum should take three to four years.
If they're severely compromised and we have to do damage repair,
we've got to heal some injuries.
We've got some chronic things.
Cause what,
what's a chronic injury?
A chronic injury is simply an injury that you kept abusing until it became
semipermanent.
That's all chronic injury as it means you slammed your hand in the door and it
hurt.
Okay.
And your,
your response to slamming your hand in the door to earning was to keep slamming
your hand in the fucking door.
You kept slamming in the door and you say,
God,
my hand really hurts.
Where at,
what should I do?
What should I do?
I said,
well,
quit slamming your hand in the damn door and it will get better.
But people,
they don't,
they don't really,
they don't think that way.
There's like,
well I,
but I really,
really like doing this and we get people coming to us really beat up cause we're
taught no pain,
no gain.
Well we flipped that around.
We say no brain,
no game.
Now we're not talking about the pain of fatigue.
They're the easy way to know.
The difference between fatigue and injury is simply the sharpness of the pain.
So for example,
and it's some experience also.
So if you,
if you're feeling you feeling pain right,
and maybe it's from a core workout and you stop,
you're doing hollow body rocks,
whatever it via,
it doesn't matter what you're doing,
sit ups,
you stop.
If it's fatigue,
it's immediately going to start to lessen.
As soon as soon as you stop,
the pain starts going away.
If it's an injury and you stop,
it's immediately gonna continue,
begin increasing.
That's your oh shit moment.
That's Ah,
I have screwed myself up.
Right.
And so you Kinda,
you kinda have to ride that we want,
we want to work to where the body is working,
but we don't want to work so hard.
It's like for a long time it was a big thing for people doing kipping pull ups
to take pictures of their hands being raw and bloody from their rips.
And they were looking at it as a badge of honor.
You know that I worked so hard and in the short term for that,
for that moment,
yes.
Yeah.
They worked really hard.
Now I looked at it differently.
I looked at as like you stupid shit.
What are you going to do tomorrow now?
Right.
Cause there's,
there's,
there's no amount of work you can do to day that could offset the amount of
progress you could have made throughout a properly structured week.
Can't it can't
be done.
You see,
you see that with kettle bells a lot too.
I remember the,
I remember when I was really deepened in Kettlebell training.
It was a,
yeah,
you take yourself out for God knows how long you rip all your calluses off,
but they mean well,
they mean while we we,
we tend to use two terms with our athletes.
We have immature athletes and mature athletes and definition,
and it's not an age deal.
It's,
it's an attitude DL,
so an immature athlete is someone who wants what they want right now.
Okay.
A mature athlete is someone who's willing to do what needs to be done now to
Gary awarded for it later.
The delayed gratification,
and it's the mature athlete that in the long run always comes out on top.
They're always the ones with the greater longevity in the greater success.
The other ones,
the image.
Sure ones,
if they're really talented,
they may stay ahead for a while,
but eventually you're going to get so dinged and broken and beat up that they
have to step aside and the mature guy in the mature athlete,
or I'm a woman right there,
they're just doing their thing day in,
day out.
It's like a writing a book that has 365 pages in it.
If I,
if I ask you tomorrow,
Tim,
go home tonight and write me a book with 365 pages.
You like,
Chris,
you've lost your fucking mind.
But if I say,
Tim,
I want you to write me a page,
a single page.
Every day in a year we've got a book with 365 pages and if you picture that,
that thickness of a novel that that's a lot of pages there.
But if I look at that thickness of a single page,
it's so thin that it seems negligible and it doesn't even matter.
It's like,
why?
Why did I bother?
Well,
it's,
it's the consistency that adds up over time.
That's where you see,
you see these great athletes,
got to understand,
they see you see a world class athlete that did not start training yesterday.
There's a multi year process.
Well also I think that there is a behavioral modification and a component of
this,
which you know,
if you wanted to dig in the resource into the researchers is supported this
point which is doing each day less than you feel maximally capable of is it's,
it's a fantastic sort of po positive reinforcer.
And this applies in the supplies in sales.
This is what IBM did way back in the day when their salesforce was slaughtering
the competition.
They had the lowest quotas in the industry because they wanted their salespeople
to be unintimidated to pick up the phone so we could substitute intimidated and
I got the phone with intimidated to go to the gym or start a session.
You can also apply it to writing.
I'll leave a little in the bank.
They've lived in the bank.
I remember,
uh,
the,
there were two examples offhand as it applies to writing.
A friend of mine who's very,
very consistent,
prolific writer and he said,
my key is every day I write less than I feel capable of.
And they know a guideline that I was given was two crappy pages per day.
That's all you have to do.
Two crappy pages.
And sometimes you overshoot that and you have a great workout and you're feeling
as you put it froggy,
right,
you're feeling fancy,
they're feeling fantastic and you just blow through it and set a bunch of prs.
But you didn't go into the workout with the pressure of having to achieve prs
and every exercise and uh,
you know,
Hemingway not maybe not the gray,
the best life model,
but was prolific writers still listed and he would,
he would end mid sentence,
he would end still feeling like he had more to say in a specific paragraph or
sentence so that he had a place to pick up the next day,
the a of that.
And so on the point of consistency,
and actually I want you to finish your last thought because I totally hijacked
the conversation,
but you said it takes three to date.
Jack my thoughts.
So three,
three to four,
three to four years to to get them to what percentage of their genetic
and that,
and this is ballpark 75 to 80 and this,
this is just an example to people cause the body,
the body will not let you run it.
100% won't do it.
Won't do it.
There's not enough optimal surplus that we mentioned earlier,
three to four years to get to 75 80% it will take me another three to four
years,
another three to four years to get to about 90%
another three to four years.
And then after that it will take me another three to four years to get to about
95% and that's me riding herd on them.
That's my standards.
Right?
Cause member,
it's easier for me to maintain that immaculate standard because I'm not the one
feeling the fatigue right now.
Okay.
As much easier you gets very difficult for a world class athlete to train
themselves.
Right.
And it doesn't do a good a worldclass coach any good to have all that knowledge
in his head.
It takes a partnership,
right?
It takes both of them working together to create this great athletic animal.
So,
but the interesting thing is that another three to four years to get the 95% and
as soon as they ease up,
the body drops back down to that 75 80 that's where likes now to build back up,
won't take nearly as long as to build it in the first place.
Okay.
Because the structures are already in place,
nervous systems are developed,
Yadi,
Yadi Yada,
Yada Yada.
But that's where the bodies comfortable.
So as far as adults are concerned,
okay,
are they,
does a 35 year old need to be able to produce at 90% no,
they don't.
Do they need at 95% no,
they're,
they're not full time professional athletes.
They don't,
they don't have time for that.
Can they produce at 75 80% yes they can.
And the interesting thing is is,
well that puts you on the Olympic team now.
Absolutely.
Absolutely not.
Are you going to be close to it now?
But is it,
well it puts you being better than 99 out of 100 people around you.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It will pay you there.
And if we put a percentage on that,
that means that just by being consistent,
putting some years consistent years of training in that puts you in the top 1%
of the human population in terms of physical ability.
That is not a bad consolation prize.
No,
it's,
it's not.
I want to underscore the consistency point because I've always been an intensity
guy.
Right.
I mean,
for the most part because that's my easy,
that's my default mode and it's served me when everybody's right.
Yeah,
it's served.
It's served me well.
Uh,
but there's a,
there's a point where,
you know,
the,
the sword cuts both ways and uh,
you sent me an email recently,
I'm going to replace the name just in,
unless we decide to,
as going to say or maybe take out the profanity just in case.
Yeah.
I'll take out the f bombs
dear you lazy bastard.
No,
that's not how it started.
So,
so this,
this,
I just want to,
because I want to talk about older students who have picked up gymnastics and
okay.
So there are a lot of people who are rightly I think naturally skeptical of the
ability of say 35 38 40 plus year old to acquire these skills that are
associated with people who start when they're five six seven years old.
So I'm going to replace the name with Frank.
Okay.
So I was having a hell of a lot of trouble with Tuck hops and to to just explain
that and I fully plan for everyone listening to put a lot of of video examples
in the show notes.
You'll have visual references for a lot of this,
but top cops,
it's a great exercise and there are different ways to practice this but it Tuck
handstand is instead of having your body ramrod straight from your,
your hands all the way to your pointed toes at the very top,
your,
you're basically bringing your knees to your chest or rib cage while you're in
the handstand position with your feet still pointed.
But your heels kind of touching your ass.
Is that a fair,
fair description?
I agree with that.
And I was having a lot of trouble with range of motion.
Uh,
I just couldn't get low enough.
And so coach sent me an email,
which was,
you know,
frank is one of my senior students.
Here's a video of him working his Tuck handstand compression.
While it's not exactly the same exercises does provide a nice visual example.
Now the part that stands out for me is what follows the video cause I watched
the video and was like,
okay,
that's,
that's pretty solid.
Uh,
and you said,
you know,
he started roughly two years ago out of shape,
weak and rather pudgy on his first workout.
I believe that he failed three times,
12 seconds bent hollow body hold.
And I've been there.
There are people in wheelchairs that are stronger in that.
Yeah.
And I prob probably going to get the [inaudible] not going to do this exercise
justice,
but I mean a bent hollow by they hold is effectively like imagine if you're in
a,
in a crunch position on the floor.
Right.
And then you put your arms just kind of kind of pick your feet up,
like you were going to do a sit up,
except don't
set up shoulders up a little off the ground,
feed off a little ground,
and then just try to rock back and forth.
That's it.
So he filled that 12,
couldn't do three sets of that times 12 second,
couldn't do it.
Not a chance.
Fast forward two years,
and he's a beast in there.
There were two recipes.
There are two points here that really,
uh,
left the market meets.
The first was,
he's very consistent.
Okay,
we've talked about that.
But here it has the part that I really liked.
So he never rushes through exercise.
And every time he gets stuck on a progression and is not able to break through
that particular plateau,
he simply drops all the way back to the first progression and begins working his
way up.
So I want to try to illustrate this because this is a really,
cause most people,
myself included,
we'll just bang their heads against a wall with the,
with the plateau movement,
right?
So let's,
let's take the talk.
Uh,
I'm not,
I'm sorry not to talk,
but the,
uh,
the press handstand,
which we've been talking about as a great kind of bang for the buck objective
because it incorporates so many different elements and attributes that you need
to develop.
What would a series of progressions,
like four or five progressions for that look like?
And does it literally mean that if,
if,
if he couldn't get through movement five,
that he would drop all the way back to number one or would he go back to number
two and number three?
All right,
back to number one.
Okay.
Now he might,
he might go to,
he might not start with,
uh,
the very weak one programming have,
you know,
three by one rep.
He might,
he might drop back to a week 11.
You know,
where it's where we provide the programming where it's five by five and you see
demonstrate mastery then next workout bump.
But basically what,
what he's doing as if he failed on that exercise,
that means there was a chink in the armor somewhere.
There was a hole and the preparation there was at some deficit or super add.
It add up to a deaf said that had been overlooked or some part of the body that
had not yet super compensated.
So by stepping off,
so basically you want,
we want people to go through when they're in training to just be super
simplistic.
We want their training to go through a period of overload where whatever they're
doing is kicking their ass.
Okay?
It's hard.
It's intense.
And then without changing reps or sets,
right,
we want the body then to go into a period of load or that same amount of work,
that same load,
same exercise,
same rep,
same sets,
feels moderately difficult.
So it's,
it's feeling easier because the body's gotten stronger.
And then where people always cut it short,
where they,
where they undermine themselves here is they don't go into underload.
So to be super simplistic underload is where,
damn,
I'm just not feel like I'm working very hard.
You're moving the same way.
You're doing the same reps,
you're doing the same sets,
right?
But you're just,
you're just cutting it short.
People tend to do is they want to ride that razor's edge.
I did this much today.
I'm going to do this,
Ma,
I'm going to do more next week.
That typical five pounds on the bar.
Okay,
well that's,
that's great.
You know,
if that was the case,
I remember my first way to pull up work out.
I was excited.
I was excited way back when I was a teenager,
I came home and hit my five pounds.
I pulled out my calendar,
did five pounds,
I'm gonna do pound every week.
I said,
Holy Shit.
How could it be pulling 1500 pounds in a year?
Man,
I'm world champion.
World champion in the making.
Well,
linear doesn't work that way.
It doesn't work that way.
So what happens is that you hit,
you hit that point of where you're maxed out currently and then you got to step
off and we got to give the body a chance to accommodate.
So for example,
you mentioned,
you mentioned Rob Wolf.
Rob is a good buddy.
Rob,
super sharp.
For those of you who don't know,
he's a nutrition of Guru.
Checkout is stuff BB for people are OPB the ice guy.
He's got two bs there.
Well,
you know,
rob,
rob is a high intensity guy like you,
Tim.
And so I shared with them the year Allen One national sown and national
champion.
Imagine you have defeated the entire country right there.
There's one champion and your it.
Everyone.
You kicked their ass.
Unbelievable feeling extreme.
Extremely awesome.
Well,
that year I didn't change anything on Alan's conditioning the entire year.
Not,
not a damn thing.
I didn't change an exercise.
I didn't change a rep.
I didn't change a set,
not for that entire year.
So,
so,
so you mean that they're the,
for the,
for the progressive resistance purists out there,
there,
there might be another way.
Well,
but remember he wasn't a beginning and he wasn't a beginner at this point.
No,
because I beginner,
right?
It wouldn't do any good if I can do a wall push up inclined on the wall.
I mean,
Alan was strong.
He was already doing hollow back process.
You know,
rope climbs were for maintenance of healthy elbows,
Yada,
Yada.
But for that year,
I didn't change anything.
All that changed was workout.
That took an hour,
got to the point where it was taken 40 to 45 minutes.
At which point do your stretching it out because the less time you're in the gym
the better.
Okay.
Cause it's less wear and tear on the body.
Think,
think of it.
You know when,
when I hear what you mentioned,
you know people who love to be high intensity.
Okay,
it's cool.
But the,
the analogy that comes to mind is someone who wants to be high intensity all the
time.
It's like having a new set of tires and every time you come up to a stop sign,
you don't gradually break.
You slam those brakes hard.
Use Skid to a stop.
Every single stop sign.
How long has that pair of tires going to last?
It's not,
it's going to wear out pretty quick.
And the body now,
the body's not like tires.
It can rebuild itself as long as you don't put it too deep into a hall are
physically
break the structure,
damage the structure beyond repair.
So you know as long,
as long as you show some degree of care,
you rebuild yourself.
But if you keep skin to that stop every single day,
right?
Matter of time,
now advertise,
not if it's,
it's guaranteed.
So let's,
let's,
let's uh,
throw out a couple of,
I'll use another automotive metaphor.
Let's switch gears and I will ask just a couple of questions that I think people
would love to hear answers to.
Uh,
the first is someone's listens to this,
they're extremely excited to do gymnastic strength training and maybe they go
out and they're like sampling different things from all sorts of different
places.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
of course I have no business I should say with full disclosure.
I have no business association.
I'm not getting any kind of affiliate.
Anything from you.
I just am a real fan of how you train.
So I think people should check out and shape your,
your,
your training programs.
But what exercises should people not attempt or just removed from consideration
for the first say six months of gymnastic strength training?
Probably such a good question.
I would say muscle ups.
Um,
the issue becomes,
is nothing wrong with the pole.
There's nothing wrong with the debt.
Uh,
the shoulders will adapt relatively quickly and you know,
they'll get up on rings at first and they're shaking.
And that's simply because the stabilizers aren't used to the load.
But that that'll adapt within,
you know,
two weeks,
four weeks,
there'll be fine.
The issue they run into is because their shoulder extension as weak.
They can't get the elbow behind the torso.
So instead of doing a dip with bodyweight,
now they're trying to do a tricep extension with bodyweight.
Completely different animal,
completely different animal.
As you know,
they're kind of have,
their elbows can't go,
their elbows are trapped at their side and now their hands are in front of them
and they're just trying to press himself up.
Of course,
they're just trash and they're always,
no,
some people,
okay,
we do see it.
Some people have incredible joints that you can just pound and pound and pound
and pound and pound.
Nothing happens to him.
Run him over with a car.
I all you're going to do is hurt your car.
Everyone assumes they're that guy there,
that woman.
The reality is you're not guys,
you are not that person.
If you were that person,
I would see you at training camps right now,
or you would be a celebrator professional level athlete.
So accept the fact that you're human and those are not your joints.
And so you,
you can't take that approach and have longevity is not going to happen.
So there you guys,
a muscle ups go out,
it must loves go out.
Now how do they get around the muscle up?
How do they get,
cause it's their elbows hurt and they can't do a slow,
we need to build strength.
We got to do it slow.
Right?
How do they get around?
They do the kipping muscle up.
Okay,
well that gets me on top of the rings.
But where I get the benefit of muscle ups is through that transition is I'm
going between the pullup through my chest,
up of them.
That's where it crosses,
that's where plan jazz,
that's where Maltese is.
That's where all advanced ring strength is.
It's,
it's that strength when you,
when you see a gymnast,
right when you see him this summer at the Olympics,
right?
And we're,
we just as an aside guys,
we've got,
and we've got some podcasts coming out for gymnastic by,
sorry,
Tim competing with here.
That's all right.
And we're going to talk some train and right with,
with summer by the Olympic guys.
And when you,
when you see them,
right,
you are a,
you're going to see this massive musculature and it didn't come from pushups and
it didn't come from dips.
It came from that advanced ring strength.
They do.
So if you're doing a kipping muscle up and you're going from below the rings too
on top of the range and it's gone,
you just skip the most beneficial part of the muscle up.
[inaudible]
let me ask you a related question because of course,
every four years,
uh,
I watch gymnastics.
I love watching gymnastics as do a lot of people when they go,
Holy Shit,
if I can get arms that look like that by hanging from a bar for an hour a day,
I need to start hanging from a bar.
How much of,
I know we talked about the rings,
how much of the musculature in the upper arms,
biceps specifically comes from straight arm work versus some form of bent arm
work?
Excellent.
Excellent question.
So the majority of the massive biceps they see is going to come from the
straight arm work.
Uh,
we use self for example,
when the guys would,
uh,
at that level of training at that level of strength.
Uh,
rope climbs for example.
So my,
my guys had to do a triple on a seven meter rope.
So that's what,
no,
all rope climbs are done with no legs.
Okay.
And GST,
we do ropes without legs.
We get,
some people say,
and all the rope is used for transportation.
As soon as they take out the escalators in a mall and they put ropes in,
in place of it,
or they take the elevators out and they put ropes,
I'll buy that argument that we use a rope for transportation until that happens.
Or rope is used for getting freaking strong.
Right?
That's the point of how in a row.
So they would,
they would in five minutes they would do a triple on a seven meter rope,
get in the back of the line,
do a double on a seven meter,
get back in the line and do another and that'd be about five minutes worth of
work.
Okay.
Now for them,
what we did notice,
and a lot of people miss this oriented two things here at once.
So for the maximal strength component of it,
it's the straight arm work,
Maltese work in particular or it just blows the body out,
Blah.
And people listening don't just go into your garage and try a Maltese on your
rings,
but you can,
you can totally cause I don't think Maltese will hurt you.
That ball is won't hurt you,
but you are landing on the concrete,
on your face.
Underneath the rings is probably going to hurt.
The multis won't.
It's the sudden stop at the end.
That will be uncomfortable.
But uh,
now what we found out with the guys though is,
uh,
you know we did over the years,
the,
the weight vests,
the weights,
the heavy,
the heavy weighted row kinds pullups nothing better mass on a bicep secondary
from the ring strength,
then high volume rope climbs,
nothing.
Nothing blew them up.
Now the key though is,
is for everybody listening.
If you go and you jump right into ropes right now and you haven't built a
foundation of rows pull ups,
multiplane pulling and then get to rope climbing,
right?
You're going to give yourself a raging case of elbow tendonitis.
Yeah.
Your elbows are going to just
disintegrate.
Yup.
So like anything else,
you gotta pay your dues.
But if you go through the proper steps and you're prepared to do rope climbs
there,
there is nothing American is the Bicep is an endurance muscle that that's its
job,
right?
It,
it,
it's,
it's job isn't to how am I now it can do this,
but its primary function is not to how much can I do that heaviest load for one
rep,
it's primary function is go out and kill something,
pick it up and carried it a long ass way back home that that's its primary job.
That's his primary job.
So it just blossoms from high volume work.
Now the key is is that it's got to be high volume with her reasonably high load,
which on the rope climbs his bodyweight.
But we,
we've got to build to that.
So to two things that I'll throw out there just because people might find it
interesting.
So the first is you can build extremely muscular biceps.
This is not gymnastics related,
but with purely straight arm,
heavy,
heavy pulling in the deadlift can unwind with let's just,
let's just say you had one day of heavy polling and by heavy I mean two to three
reps,
like to the knees,
kind of like the Barry Ross Protocol and the four hour body stop.
No centrix you know,
drop it.
And then let's say you do that on Mondays and then on Fridays or Thursdays,
whatever it might be,
you do higher up kettle bell swings,
two armed kettlebell swings.
You can get really,
really muscular arms without doing any work whatsoever.
Um,
and uh,
also when we're talking about an easy enough to switch that high rep Kettlebell
work to a throw rope climb on Friday,
if you are advanced enough,
if your elbows are bulletproof enough,
which mine are not as,
as an example for folks like I've done plenty of rowing but my,
when I have,
here's the difference though,
when I have a parallel grip,
right?
So if you all,
if you're like,
I can pull fuck that,
I can do bet rows of the barbell with 225 pounds and whatever,
and you think that you're the king of pulling.
If you don't do a lot of parallel grip work or a fat bar work and then you go to
a thick rope,
you're in for a surprise surprise.
They maybe we should touch base on the difference real quick between the various
grips.
Yeah,
please.
Okay.
So
guys in,
in terms of GST specific strength,
if you were doing just pull up work,
your parallel grip is by far by far going to have the greatest return on
investment,
uh,
simply because that parallel grip,
it's the brachy Alice.
So hard down in the elbow.
The reason we need that is when you climb a rope,
you're going to have more of a parallel grip.
You do that parallel Grep pull up.
Obviously you're developing that when we're on the rings were on top of the
range,
right?
Cause we always,
every,
everything is aimed for eventually getting under the rings to build strength.
So when you're on the rings,
we need the grip turned out past parallel.
Now back in the day,
Greg Glassman and I,
Greg is the,
you know,
he's super bright guy,
founder across fit,
but he just didn't understand why we would turn the rings pass parallel.
He thought it was just the aesthetics coach.
It's just aesthetics.
Well,
the problem is if I'm on the rings and I do a dip,
I do a muscle up,
I do whatever,
and I straighten my arms and I don't turn the rings past parallel.
Nope.
I apologize for interrupting just for people to visualize this.
So let's just say you're on tips.
You're in between the straps,
your,
I'm sorry,
you're,
you're up on rings and you're doing dips and you're in between the straps.
What in,
correct me if I'm wrong here coach,
but when you get to the top,
that means top of the rep onto,
I'm straight off of the rep and your arms are straight that your,
the rings are concerned the thumbs out slightly.
So instead of having the rings parallel pointing straight ahead or turned in,
which is what most port turned in,
they would be at say 10:00 PM and 2:00 PM or something like that.
Exactly.
Then it will vary.
As long as they're out.
Now they're re the reason is is all straight.
What's the weak link and straight arm strength is the elbow.
The weak link is the elbow.
And what a lot of people will do is we,
we've had people who were taught,
well,
elbow pain is just part of doing ring strength.
No,
it's not.
Elbow pain is an indicator that your ring strength is aft up and you need to do
better programming and it hurts for a reason.
And I took you off track though just because I wanted people to,
to visualize the proper thing.
So you were saying to Greg that when you get to the top,
you know,
the issue is it's not just aesthetics.
When you get to the top,
not a settings,
you've got to turn past parallels so that the brachy Alice is activated.
Right?
There's a reason that after all these years of crossfit being on reigns and
doing thousands upon thousands of kipping pull ups and dips and all that stuff,
that there are no iron crosses unless they are previous gymnast,
right?
There's no homegrown crossfitter who has an iron cross,
snow home fit homegrown crossfitter who has a plant or a malt because right from
the beginning and those very basic movements,
they didn't turn pass parallel.
They didn't turn the rings out.
The brachy Alice wasn't trained.
The brachy owls is what supports the elbow when it's straight.
So if it never got trained,
they can never move forward into the money making exercises.
So that's why in those parallel,
those pull ups,
if we use a parallel grip and it's easy enough to do something,
just just do a set right,
do a nice parallel,
a nice parallel grip workout and then compare the soreness that you feel on the
inside of the elbow from fatigue,
right.
Compared to regular chin ups and regular pullups it's night and day then then we
would do chins and then pull ups.
Got It.
But so the,
the um,
other exercises to remove,
if any.
So we have muscle ups back lever down and he's the love back lever.
And you would add to that list,
you know,
and this,
this one is a little unfortunate.
It's a,
and I don't know that it's so much of a removing has a deep prioritizing.
Yeah.
A cautionary tale.
So it takes,
it takes time to rebuild connective tissue and it's connective tissue right
through the,
through the ligaments.
And the joints that generate power through the body when they're doing
plyometric work.
So there,
there was a rash of Achilles ruptures when there was a couplet done of hot.
So they were doing deads I believe with 225 pounds.
And then that was coupled with box jumps
and they were doing that for rounds.
Okay.
And,
and there's,
there's not a problem with either one of those in isolation.
The problem came when he was in a competitive environment with most of the
adults.
Right.
We're in there their later twenties and their thirties you know that the,
the,
the typical people who are working out and because it's a race,
the box jumps turned into jumping down also,
which turned into rebounding,
apply a metric off the floor cause I got to get these done right.
I'm in a race.
So they had pre fatigue,
the Achilles with the deadlift and then when into the plyometric of the box
jump.
Nothing wrong with either one of them,
but in combination it took some people,
I think they had,
there were like nine ruptures that year of which is,
you know,
one okay.
It happens.
Right?
Yvonne cough had it,
had his achilles,
he was one of the leading guys were looking to from a Russia,
Yvonne,
Yvonne cough,
former world champ who uh,
he was,
he was the top guy that was favored to win the gold at the 96 games cause it
killed these pop to walking across the parking lot.
Now is it because walking across the parking lot is a dangerous thing and we
should all avoid parking lots?
No,
it just happened to be the last straw and it had been damaged prior to that,
which I,
long story short,
you went back to the front split series.
That is the very reason that there is that high rep calf work there to promote
Achilles' hell because there is connective tissue,
the tendons and that do not have their own blood supply.
Okay.
So they get fed,
they heal,
they strengthen through muscles moving around them and gravity.
That's what flushes the area.
So if we only do very high,
high intensity low rep work,
there's not enough blood flow for them to be healthy.
And this,
this isn't mine room.
A friend of the Bulgarian Olympic coach for,
um,
the seventies and eighties is a good friend of mine and genius genius at
programming room.
And it makes me look like a,
uh,
tottering idiot who she'd be sat in a corner and no one talked to me.
What's his name?
I can never pronounce Rumens last name.
You guys can can look them up.
Go Gary and Olympic coach for the women.
Seventies and eighties.
Our Room,
and I want to say our bastardized,
a American spelling is a r u,
m I n or m,
a n,
uh,
sadly room and had a,
a really heavy accent.
So a lot of the American coaches,
you know,
they,
they didn't want to take the time to talk to them,
but you know,
I was a linguist in the military way back when.
So accidents not as good as you,
Tim.
But accidents don't bother me.
So I would,
I would just pinned it and he was older gentleman.
I would keep this guy up late so many days or how he be Chris,
I gotta go get some say hi.
It's okay.
Just one more question.
Just one more.
So our,
our knee series that we do came from Roman.
Uh,
the one now that I've been doing that's the skiers directly from Reuben.
He,
he saw Alan when he was eight and Alan was incredibly powerful at eight years
old.
It's just unreal.
And uh,
he was getting too powerful for his frame at that age.
You know,
about a,
we're starting to hit a preliminary growth spurt and a roommate gave me that
knee series and it was about a week,
week and a half.
He knows knees weren't hurting.
They were starting to get slightly uncomfortable room and showed us that boom,
Nia,
she was gone.
Never,
never,
never again,
nothing with niece ever.
Wow.
So I have,
uh,
we,
we could talk for hours and hours more.
Uh,
but I,
I want to be respectful of your time and we can always do around two sometime if
you have the,
the,
uh,
the willingness and a,
if the audience wants,
wants more.
But I do have a couple of questions before I get into some of my usual rapid
fire that I'd love to ask him.
Do you have,
do you still have some time to chat?
Um,
I,
I'm you,
you've opened a can of worms.
I'll talk training all night.
All right,
here we,
here we go.
Then the next question is,
uh,
from one of my listeners and it's,
it's quite simply how do you mentally prep your athletes for big competition?
Uh,
when the,
when you're down to that beauty,
you go to the nationals where any,
any competition,
but specifically big competitions.
How do you and bye bye prep.
I mean mentally prep like the day of.
Is there anything in particular that you do?
It's,
it's,
it's very,
it's a very different,
um,
it kind of,
so
it starts with repetition.
So we,
we talked a little bit about training,
so,
and in,
in a nutshell and what we'll come back around and we'll fill this out.
So in the preparation prior,
right?
Successful repetitions,
It takes a certain number of repetitions to lead to competence and its
competence that leads to confidence.
And that's what leads to a successful competition.
So as Americans,
right,
we tend to be in a rush,
be in a hurry.
We,
we don't want to take a lot of Reps.
We want to get something we do at correct a few times and then we want a bump on
completely different from the Chinese approach.
Completely different from the Russian approach where they'll literally do
hundreds of repetitions before they move on to the next drill and then they're,
they're not upset about it because I understand it's a process.
As Americans,
we tend to,
we're always look now answer.
It's both a good thing and it's a curse one.
It's a good thing because it forces us to be so creative.
We're so hard charging,
we get so many things done physically.
Sometimes it kind of works against us because we don't give the body and the
nervous system a chance to stabilize.
So if you want to be confident at a competition,
you have to pay your dues and prep example.
And that's mentally and physically.
For example,
72 Olympics.
Okay.
And these are,
I was talking with about this with Dimitri billows,
her chat,
my friend world and Olympic champ.
So in [inaudible] 72 Olympics,
Olga Corbett was by all accounts going to crush everyone at the games.
She was going to crush everyone in training as they went back and the Russians
went back and they reviewed all her training.
She had over a 98% hit rate on her routines.
That meant she was almost perfect,
almost perfect.
When she went to the Games,
she had a major meltdown.
Now the question of course raises,
how is it possible for someone who was this perfect for this long in training to
go to the competition and just fall apart?
As they dug into it,
they found out the error was not in physical preparation.
The error was in mental preparation,
so as Olga was cranking at home,
she was the one who decided when to go.
Coach waited on her,
judges waited on her,
everything was structured around her.
She was very comfortable.
Okay.
She didn't start till she was ready should equipments.
She's ready for lighting.
She's ready for magnums.
Familiar.
Everything is good.
When you get to the worlds and you get to the Olympics,
the judges don't give a fuck if you're ready or not when they raise that flag.
Yeah,
it's,
it's brutal.
It's brutal.
In fact,
to give everyone a little taste,
okay.
The warmup,
Jim is not there.
The warmup Jim might be 10 minutes away or it might be a 10 minute while I have
five minute walk down this concrete hallway.
So you go and you warm up,
you walk down this hallway,
right?
And then your ass weights there and then at the flag goes up and you got to go
to 100% within seconds,
you got 30 seconds to be on the equipment.
Massive head.
Yeah.
Massive head game.
So they went back and they found out that old cause problem was that everything
had gone her way.
She controlled too many variables,
too many variables.
And it,
there was,
they were too easy.
They were to accommodating.
And so what they did is the Russians changed their training just to screw with
people.
So if I'm coaching someone right and it's going,
there's going to be a mental component.
I'm going to fuck with them,
right.
I'm going to tell him and not,
not in a mean way,
but all right,
you're up and then walk away.
They will wait.
And you know,
let him,
let him get antsy.
Make them go when they're not ready.
Make them do a cold set.
Okay?
Don't,
don't let any,
any and everything.
You can have a crowd of people around them trying to mess with them any and
everything.
And I,
and I will also say it's,
it's much harder for women than it is for guys simply because women are more
caring and nurturing than guys.
Guy Goes out to compete and he's worried about one thing he's worried about
kicking ass.
Okay.
The girl goes out there and she's worried about kicking ass also,
but she's also worried about not wanting to let anybody down.
Are they going to be disappointed with me?
Are they going to like me?
She has this whole range of other emotional burdens that a guy doesn't give a
shit about.
They didn't just don't care.
I've seen girls who are just amazing and training and get out there and it's
just cause they have this other load that they place on themselves at guys don't
have to deal with.
And the way you handled that and training is we just have to get more reps in a,
you gotta have more reps and do everything you can to put them in a situation to
where,
for example,
2004 I was doing some of the prep,
I was doing some of the floor and the tramp and helping with vault and doing the
physical preparation for a girl we had trying out for the Olympics.
She did not make it done.
I mean,
you had to be top six.
She was ninth.
Okay.
And Carly,
fantastic girl.
Great girl.
They,
uh,
their approach though for mental training,
I thought was flawed.
They brought someone in and you know,
I won't,
I won't say names,
I'll just say,
I'll just say that disagreed.
And it was,
it was a very,
they're trying to be really,
really positive.
So,
you know,
30,000 square footage and big giant yes.
Signs everywhere.
Yes,
you can.
it will be great.
Yes,
that'd be wonderful.
And the reality is it's not going to be wonderful.
It's going to be stressful.
It's going to suck.
When you are in a competition at that level,
the pressure is,
is crushing it.
It's a physical pressure that you feel on you and you still have to produce
performance at a world class level.
And the only way to handle that as we have to try to replicate that in training,
right.
So that the pressure's not going away.
The air that was known at Carly was trying to downplay the pressure.
I would say do the exact opposite.
Do the opposite.
You should go to the training to the competition and hopefully competition is
less pressure than what you go through and training now.
And that's not going to be true at and such.
But at
most things,
it should be,
the case shouldn't be the case.
So mentally,
okay.
No,
if you're scared,
oh,
let's,
let's say if you're feeling unconfident,
if you're feeling threatened,
uneasy,
your preparation was flawed.
Well that's,
it brings up an anecdote that I heard from,
uh,
Paul Levesque better known as triple h,
the professional wrestler who's also an incredible,
uh,
business executive for WWE,
but he visited,
uh,
let me get this right.
Why am I blanking on his name?
I've caught whatever you,
you,
you were,
you were dealing with earlier.
Uh,
not Roy Jones,
very famous boxer,
a Floyd Mayweather.
That's it.
And he visited Floyd,
uh,
maybe an hour before a huge title fight for a championship belt or to retain his
belt.
And at one point Paul said,
you know,
I'm going to leave.
I don't want to interrupt your prep.
And he goes,
why would you interrupt me,
interrupt my prep?
He goes,
if I'm not ready now,
nothing I do between in the next 60 minutes,
it's going to make me ready.
He said,
I love that attitude.
Yeah.
Feel free to hang out.
He's just walking,
you're watching basketball or something.
And,
uh,
it also,
you brought up the,
uh,
this seal team,
six members and so on earlier.
I mean,
that's a,
I think a great example of a parallel track,
right?
In the sense that they very much want to sweat more,
in some cases,
bleed more in training so that they can avoid dying in real battle.
So the simulations are extremely brutal.
Uh,
and intended to be a sort of along the lines of on,
I'm,
I'm not,
not really up on my ancient name pronunciation,
but I think it's archaea locusts,
uh,
who said,
we do not rise to the level of our hopes.
We fall to the level of our training.
Um,
perfect.
So making the conditions equivalent of perfect side,
my,
my buddy would tell he they are so well trained,
no stress,
how,
how in the world you can be in 145 gun fights and not feel stressed when you're
heading out to another one.
He just,
yeah,
fall asleep on the helicopter.
You know,
I'll do my thing and get back on.
And I was seriously,
he was like,
oh yeah,
I mean,
Gosh,
and just,
just another day in the office.
I,
holy moly.
So,
uh,
so on the day,
on the day of assuming you've done the requisite preparation,
you've,
you've conditioned them to perform well under stressful circumstances,
any type of change,
change,
nothing changed,
nothing for where people fail.
Okay?
So this,
this is the end.
This is this an important lesson,
not just in competing but in everything.
So a lot of people psych themselves out of doing as well as they could have by
prematurely comparing themselves to the people around them
instead of just out,
take
care of your business,
do your best,
and see where it falls,
right?
If,
if you're going up against the best who's ever been born,
right?
You're not,
you're not going to beat them.
There's not going to be a miracle.
This guy's not going to open,
guys not going to reach down and bless you with extra athletic ability and
y'all,
this is not going to happen.
So you just,
you just ignore that,
you know,
you go out and you just stay in your own head and do your thing.
Now,
psychologically,
people handle it differently.
Some people.
I know we had,
we had the same,
the same chemistry on Olympic teams.
Some people like to be left alone,
you know,
let,
let me go do my thing.
You know,
they'll come together for the team,
but then when they're prepping for their set,
you know,
they got to go off on their self.
There's other guys where they feed off that interaction,
right?
They want people coming around and getting them pumped up and then there's all
in between.
None of them are right and none of them are wrong.
It just is what it is and it's important to just deal with who you are.
St Same and training.
Right.
There are some people who thrive on multiple training per day,
right.
And they just blossom.
They do awesome.
There's other people who have to train just a few times a week.
It doesn't matter.
There's been Olympic champions who trained both ways.
It just depends on what your body does best with.
If,
if you were sending a,
I'm very curious to hear the answer to this.
This was from a,
I think it was,
it might've been a mother.
I think it was a father who said,
uh,
what questions would coach summer ask a gymnastic coach at the,
you know,
fee a nearby facility before sending his own five to 10 year old off to train
with them.
Yeah.
And I went through that.
So I didn't,
I didn't coach my daughter,
I didn't coach my daughter.
I want it to be dad and uh,
yeah.
And I'll,
I I didn't get involved with it.
Were there things I would have done very differently?
Yes.
But uh,
her happiness in the process was more important to me than her 6,000.
She was state champion but that was more important to me then stepping in and
making sure everything was worldclass Lao,
I didn't want to go there.
Um,
first thing I would do if I'm reviewing someone cause everyone,
have you noticed that if we look at the bell curve is reality,
right?
The bell curve shows that there are,
there is a huge majority of people who are average.
There's too few are at the top and there are a few are at the bottom.
But if you talk to someone,
you've never met anyone who says,
yeah,
I'm in the middle of the bell curve.
Every fucker you talked to his exceptional,
every single person,
right?
Every person has another millionaire in the making there or another,
they're going to win the voice.
They got academy award.
It's common.
Nobody says,
yeah,
I'm average.
And it's the same thing with gyms.
So first thing I would do is look at competitive record.
How have they done and at what level have they been successful?
So are they successful at a local level,
at a state level?
How have they done in terms of regionals?
How have they done in terms of nationals a,
are they on national team?
How consistently have they been on national team as a year in,
year out?
Was it a onetime deal?
After I look at that,
the very next thing I'm going to look at it,
I'm going to look at injury rates.
You know,
how how healthy and successful are these athletes?
How would you find that data?
Or would you just ask them point blank?
Well,
well there if,
if they're,
if they're a worldclass coach,
they're always going to be straight with you.
The only people in my experience who talk shit or the wannabes
in everything that I've in everything I had.
So 2003 uh,
yeah,
it's 2003 I'm at a training camp and Paul Hom has just won the world
championships.
He's just won worlds.
And Alan is a little guy who are,
were at a training camp and in Paul's coach Stacy Malani is there and we're,
we're at a technical meeting and it's on round off on round offs of all things.
And so Stacey comes and he sits down next to me.
He says,
Chris,
what do you think about this?
Now in my head I'm thinking,
who gives a fuck what I think about this?
You just won world championships.
I want to know what you think about this.
But he asked my opinion.
I don't say I'm not going to be rooted Stacy,
but in my head I'm thinking that.
So we talk about it for a little bit and then Stacy gets up and he goes around
the room visiting with other coaches that he respect and you wants their opinion
and then he,
he makes his own opinion that a print out,
he had just won world.
So it had been so easy for him to be kind of aloof and snooty and arrogant.
You know,
I'm this and that.
But the point is that that's the reason that Casey,
that Stacy one worlds,
that he was a coach of that caliber because he was always open to learning more.
He never said,
I know everything.
Right.
And like you said,
I've never met an exception.
It's,
it's the ones who aren't at a high level who think,
you know,
I know everything.
There's nothing left to be learned and it's just not the case.
So I would,
I would check that chuck around Y'all talk to people,
watch the athletes and training,
you know,
they'll go and watch some workouts.
How does the coach handle it?
Is there a lot of tears now?
If it's,
if it's,
if it's a guy and there's tears in the work and he's got a broken leg,
right?
The first deaf and girl and girls,
you know,
girls are girls.
I,
I live in,
uh,
I've got two daughters,
a wife,
even my dog is female.
There's,
there's tiers here constantly.
This is part of being female.
So if it's an occasional tier,
no big deal.
But if there's a lot of crying all the time there a problem,
I'd,
I'd moved down the road.
But if,
if they're happy now,
doesn't
healthy doesn't mean a free for all.
Healthy and happy doesn't mean indulging,
you know,
there should be structured,
there should be accountability,
but it should be pleasant.
You know,
kids,
kids or any athlete,
adults as well.
Well,
either live up to the standards you set or they will live down to the standard
you set.
So I can just kind of go in and try to try to get a feel,
you know,
is,
is this a place where you are?
Is that the compound petition?
Record
is good.
Is this an environment that I'm content with my child being in?
You know,
if you get a good feeling.
Okay.
As an adult,
if you were assessing a gymnastics coach for yourself and you could observe a
workout,
uh,
let's just say you could only watch the warmup,
what would excellent,
what would you look for to be there or not be there?
Or what would the characteristics be?
Do they,
do they take the time to warm up the joints or did they jump right into work?
You know,
do they actually take time to mobilize?
Are they doing stall bar work?
Are they doing Jefferson curl work?
Are they,
are they loosen up their rest and their knees and their ankles or anything
loosening their back before they get gone?
Are they doing some type of pre strength?
Are they doing lower level strength elements to get the muscles warm and firing
before jumping into the hard work?
A lot.
You can tell a lot from how a program warms up.
No,
that's why I was asking and a great question.
Yeah,
there's,
I mean there's a movement that also from an evolutionary standpoint,
it makes a lot of sense.
Just like we were talking about the biceps and high,
high capacity for volume,
the QL walks,
which you introduced me to it,
which if you really want to have people laugh at you,
this is,
uh,
this is a great move to do a,
although you had mentioned,
and this doesn't surprise me at all,
it's that you've,
you've seen high level power lifters use it doing this.
That's where,
that's where I got it.
Yeah.
Holding onto kettlebells,
kind of with the goblet squat type of grip.
And so what this looks like folks,
we've already talked about this,
this seated pike position.
So you're sitting on your ass legs together like straight.
So basically keeping your legs completely straight.
If there are other,
if there are other elements,
please let me know.
Coach t technical points.
But basically you're like walking your ass cheeks,
uh,
back and back and feel it.
You look like a retard doing a speed walking,
sitting down.
Yeah.
That's actually,
that's a great description.
That's exactly what it looks like.
And uh,
you,
uh,
Ql,
or I say refers to the quality.
I would screw it up.
Yeah.
Quadratus lumborum yeah.
Quarters,
Laura,
which is sort of like the grand central of all sorts of muscles and Fascia in
the back and uh,
it's incredible how much that loosens up my entire lower back and hips,
uh,
doing this very,
very simple QL walk.
But uh,
I'll pick up guys sometimes three,
four inches.
Oh yeah.
Just,
just from loosening up from those first.
Yeah.
And the uh,
you know,
how long should a proper gymnastics warmup take and,
and one more,
which is warming up the joints.
Other,
any specific movements that that hit the shoulders from any angle or perspective
that would see they would indicate a
better warmup for gymnastic strength training than others?
It would depend on duration,
duration of the workout.
So if you're,
if you're in there for an hour,
yeah,
I'll,
I'll preface it,
say you're in for an hour.
I would say probably 10 to 15 minutes is reasonable.
Now at the same time,
if I have significant mobility deficits,
then perhaps the majority of the workout and needs to be mobility work.
So a,
it could kind of shift possibly as high as a half hour.
If I have a multi hour training coming up,
it's,
it's complicated enough and we've,
we've tried this over the years there,
there are enough things to address that that should be addressed on a semi
regular basis that you can't really get everything in to a single warmup.
So you probably going to have two or three variations.
You know,
if you're doing an advanced work,
you're probably going to have two or three variations in order to get to
everything.
Like for example,
rings,
drank before a good heart during strength.
It's very nice to do theraband series for the shoulders,
you know,
different,
different shapes and poles and circles and all these things with their Urbana.
Really great for warming up the interior of the shoulder on other days.
Do I need to do that as much for shoulder?
No,
it might be more weighted shoulder work as appropriate for other days is a
necessary,
you do all of them at the same time?
Most of the time.
No.
Uh,
we have one senior student really,
really good.
Um,
Matt started training with me in his late forties.
Uh,
he's now 50 to be east press handstands,
plan judges a front levers,
uh,
at 52 ridiculous shape.
And he went through a period where just for shoulders to feel better,
he did every shoulder prep.
We had all our integrated mobile at our courses are set up very unusually where
for our introductory courses,
uh,
the students,
adult students come in alternate an exercise with an integrated mobility because
we want them 50,
50.
It's,
we found if I,
if I told people how important stretching was,
they always blew me off.
But if I required it do a set and before your next set you have to do this
stretch than back and forth.
And we just had great results.
So mats is a crazy maniac still.
It's still skateboard still.
Waterskiis does all does as GST and a shoulder get a little finicky.
So he just did extra mobility and it just fixed a shoulder right up.
I was introduced to a,
an exercise by a masters crossfit competitor actually that really helped with
shoulder,
I would say warm up more than mobility but for pressing exercises even in GST,
including any type of hand balancing or his dad work,
which then you have
to have a decent man of grip strength for this.
But I was very skeptical as skeptical of this,
even as someone who's done a lot with kettle bells.
But I've never been a huge fan of the bottoms up work with kettlebells.
Meaning you're,
it's got it flipped up.
You're gripping it by the handle.
The fell on top A.
Exactly.
But this,
I was like,
you know what?
Screw it.
I'll try it with a lightweight.
And I started with say whatever it is,
might be like 15,
16 pounds and I've,
I've,
I've increased that I'd be,
he's 35 now,
but it a little bit of chocolate goes a long way here.
But you,
you would,
uh,
you basically say swing it up to a clean and then press it overhead and then you
just do rotations,
some doing like side to side rotations and it's incredible how well that
activates the smaller musculature eyes and the shoulders.
So wonderful in it.
Oh it's cool.
We didn't do them with kettle.
We'll do on with a light dumbbells.
So basically guys will,
what Tim's is driving is just take,
take a Dumbbell,
push it up,
overhead,
turn,
turn the thumbs externally rotated just a bed and then just do how it words
circles and uh,
keep a flat back.
Shoulders open,
no arching and uh,
doing for time.
One to two minutes.
How just good gracious,
wonderful,
warm up.
And then,
you know,
something we didn't address and I'll throw it in just real,
real,
real quick.
I know,
I know we're running out of time,
but um,
some people who are experiencing shoulder issues in terms of mobility and on to
do with the shoulder or necessarily the Bicep,
but some ninjas cause the lats are so strong and tie.
And so I have absolutely,
exactly.
I'll a lot of and because,
and a lot of the lifters to cause those are,
those lats are working on,
you guys are moving some serious weight and those lats are coursework and,
and if there's not a corresponding mobility going with it,
it's real easy for those last to kind of get chronically contracted,
losing their mobility.
So a lot of times you get in there and just stretch the heck out of that lot.
Automatically get relief on the shoulders.
Okay.
Coach,
I got,
I am going to do a couple of rapid fire than a couple of closing questions and
then maybe,
uh,
I mean you and I are talking quite a bit these days,
so we'll look,
consider doing a followup and I'm,
I definitely want to share the sort of,
the results of our experiment with people also.
So we'll certainly be in constant contact,
but the,
the first rapid fire question is,
and the answer doesn't have to be short,
but it certainly can be.
When you think of the word successful,
who is the first person who comes to mind for you and why?
Wow,
good question.
Well,
it's not Obama,
not Obama piss all the people off out there
and on.
Someone I have admired for years and years is a Tony Robbins.
So he would be very high on my list.
Uh,
I tend to be very eclectic.
I'm not,
uh,
not trapped just in what,
what
I found in terms of a business,
arts,
politics.
I,
it,
it's,
it's all the same.
When,
when people get to that level of success,
they all have the same attitudes.
They bring the same tools and attitudes to the table.
And,
uh,
I found it surprising that I can sit down,
I can sit down with you Tim and visit.
I can sit down with special operators and visit and uh,
I can sit down with a,
you know,
worldclass ballerinas and dance and artists in that I just did this weekend as
it,
where they'll worldclass artists and we all,
you would think there's no common ground there,
but there is common ground because what's required to head chief success in all
of those requires the same skills.
You gotta be consistent.
You got to master the basics.
You gotta be patient.
Now you've got to constantly reinvent yourself.
Look,
look for a flaw hole on the preparation,
they exit,
move forward.
But you also have to be very observant and I think part of training yourself to
be observant as I like that,
asking questions,
right?
So I think that's,
and being willing to hear the answer,
definitely.
That's why you take a bunch of people who are the best at what they do and you
put them in the room,
generally speaking,
they're going to get along just fine.
Absolutely.
Uh,
the,
now why Tony Robbins?
I mean,
I'm a huge fan of Tony Robbins.
He's,
he's,
he's been on the podcast and I have tremendous respect for him,
but I want to just hear your reasons.
I like,
I like that.
I firmly believe,
especially in the u s I firmly believe that if,
if someone isn't as successful in any arena,
you toss it out,
whether it's professionally,
personally in your life,
financially,
if you're not as successful as you would like to be,
are making progress towards that.
It's our own fault we have,
we have so many opportunities here that,
gosh,
so,
so much wealth of knowledge that a lot of times,
so for example,
when GB got started,
okay,
there were two years,
a year and a half,
two years in the beginning where I was doing 18 hour days and didn't make a
nickel,
nothing.
And everyone around me was like,
what are you doing?
And Nah,
I've got plans for this.
And we talk about a little bit and they're like,
well,
you know,
if you need some extra money,
you could go get a job.
Think about how much further ahead you'd be right now.
But you kind of Hit,
you have to have that vision,
right?
And then you,
once you had the vision,
you've got to be able to put practical steps to it.
And then everyone's good at that.
And I outlines the people outlined stuff all the time.
But then can you stick with it?
Right?
Because when you,
you know,
when you run your business,
Tim,
when I run my business,
there's no one telling us what to do,
right?
We're the ones to monitor ourselves.
This needs to be done,
I'm going to get it done.
And it's kind of that difference between
letting someone else being in control of your life and you choosing to be in
control of your own life now.
No,
and I,
and I this,
I know some people are going to be upsetting a coach.
You know,
I'm a single mom.
It's this,
it's that I can't,
I can't do everything I want to do.
And,
and I get that.
I get that.
I've been there,
I've gone through that and I'm not,
I'm certainly not saying there are,
there are quick fixes.
Cars,
he's,
fixes can take years.
But I think if someone's willing to put the time in that there's so much
opportunity and they're willing to do that for years.
Right.
That,
you know,
it's kind of a big giant blank check.
A lot can change you.
You really have a lot of control.
And so that,
that was a message that,
you know,
and I didn't say it nearly as well as Tony Robbins does and I am going to twist
your arms.
I gate at an introduction someday to Tony.
That's high on my list.
Yeah.
I throw a little jam session for,
for the people who are on the podcast.
So if both of you will be invited,
totally awesome.
So looking forward to that,
but you know,
way back when,
you know,
poor as could be,
uh,
hadn't been,
hadn't made national team coach yet,
was just going to starting in my coaching career,
uh,
everything that could go wrong went wrong.
And uh,
here,
here's this guy saying,
you know what,
just uh,
think clear,
plan ahead and be willing to work.
And that,
that really resonated with me.
That resonated with me and uh,
you know,
it's like kind of just had this discussion with someone this morning.
You know,
they're,
you're young.
It's a,
it's so challenging.
It's so difficult to be patient when you're 35 and you're starting to get back
in shape again.
And the hardest thing they need to do is they've got to,
especially if they were a good athlete previously,
you've got to set that attitude of having been a stud before aside,
because that body you have right now is not that studs body that you had
previously.
It could be again,
but it took time to build it the first time.
It's going to take time to rebuild it this time or personally in your life if
things aren't where you want it to be,
it's going to take time to build it there.
Yeah,
right.
I am this,
I had this Olympic weightlifting coach,
uh,
who,
I think you guys would hit it off famously,
especially if if you were both a couple of drinks in,
but,
uh,
he's dangerous,
very,
very similar approaches.
And,
uh,
he said,
you have a Ferrari engine in a Toyota Corolla chassis
that's not love.
That said,
you can't just slam on the accelerator and expect good things to happen.
But,
uh,
yeah,
Tony,
Tony is very tactical,
practical,
and I apologize if you,
if you and everybody else can hear,
uh,
metal bowls being spun around.
That's what my dog,
Molly does when she's trying to tell me that she was hungry.
She just licks and empty empty bowl and sends it spinning.
I'm like,
yes,
I get it.
I know you're hungry.
But in subtle.
Yeah,
being very subtle.
Uh,
what book or books have you given the most to other people as gifts?
Ooh,
I like that one now.
You know,
it's not so much as I'm
a big fan of,
uh,
Robert Heinlein.
Oh yeah.
Sign [inaudible] stranger in a strange land at all and just,
just all of them.
I come back to those over and over again.
The,
uh,
the theme of self reliance,
you know,
cause I,
I came from a really,
really humble,
modest family background and so I think that instills a hunger and a work ethic.
It's a little bit kind of,
uh,
kind of embarrassing actually.
It's a little bit of a Charles Dickens theme there.
You know,
it's a frustration thing.
Things weren't where we wanted them to be or where I wanted him to be and that,
you know,
how big a price,
how hard are you willing to work in order to change it?
Um,
one I'm enjoying right now and I'm just getting into it is a,
the hops tickle is the way by Ryan holiday.
Very close friend of mine.
You're killing me dude.
You're killing me.
I'm just going to hang out in your living room so I can meet all these people.
You and Ryan would hit it off.
Oh yeah,
that's,
that's a great book.
I actually,
this is a really small world,
so I actually produced the audio book for that.
He kidding me.
And you know when you were talking about preparing your athletes for the stress
as opposed to paint a painting it over with yes,
you can,
and positive psychology and really kind of sowing the seeds of their own
destruction by doing so I was thinking about stoic philosophy.
So it doesn't surprise me that you're reading the obstacle's the way,
which has become an extremely popular book among professional sports teams and
coaches.
I mean,
the Patriots Seahawks,
they've,
they've all read this.
Someone else that,
that caught my eye who had read in that led me to it was Swarts and Egger.
Oh yeah.
Gosh,
I mean comes,
comes to the states with no money in his pocket and then,
and then becomes world champion in athletics,
becomes a millionaire in business and becomes a movie star and becomes a
governor success and for different arenas in life.
Oh yeah.
Good Lord.
He's the,
he said,
he said he liked that book and I was like,
well,
good enough for me or our loads.
Uh,
he's an impressive unit.
Wouldn't really,
that's the two things that I know we're about to do it,
but the two things that also a starfish me when,
uh,
when I interviewed him for the podcast was number one,
I didn't realize in doing the research until I did the research that he became a
millionaire before he ever had his first starring role in real estate in real
estate.
Yes,
absolutely.
That gave him the ability to only audition,
not out of financial necessity,
but for the roles that he wanted.
So he could say no,
and uh,
that his highest grossing film of all time for him personally was twins because
no one wanted to make it.
And so he took a cut of the upfront payment for the salary per se to in exchange
for back end points that were abnormally large for the film,
for the film history at that point.
Yeah.
Fascinating guy.
Uh,
love that.
let's see.
What's,
uh,
do you have any particular morning rituals?
What does the first thing you do?
Morning rituals I'm sposed to do now.
The ones,
the ones that you actually have or don't have.
I tend to find as I've gotten older,
because I'm in my fifties now,
early fifties,
as,
as I've gotten older,
I find that my,
uh,
by far my most productive times or early morning,
that's when I'm sharpest.
I'm clearest.
Saw I'll,
I'll tend to get up,
you know,
pretty early before everybody else in the house,
all this up and I'll get when you get up,
it varies.
I'll get up somewhere usually between four and five.
And,
uh,
you know,
it gives me a chance,
my girls get up in a few hours and it gives me a chance for that to three hours
of just clear thought.
Maybe.
Maybe it's working on a project,
maybe it's a new manuscript in homemade,
maybe it's just an,
I indulged some reading.
The house is quiet and then I do my best if after that girls had to school and
then I get my workout in and if I'm,
if I'm consistent with that,
then my rest of the rest of my day is usually pretty golden.
Yeah.
You've already,
you've already won I him or somebody said to me,
if you win,
if you win the morning,
you've won the day.
I'm still working on it.
That's work in progress.
But I,
I definitely agree with that.
Uh,
do you drink coffee?
Do you do eat breakfast?
Do you drink coffee?
Yeah,
that's,
that's I,
I went for years.
And you know,
you're always told them I'm not a coffee drinker.
I'm,
I'm one of those few,
I think what it just tastes like cough medicine to me.
And so it's,
it's not,
it's not me being virtuous.
It's just me mean despising the taste.
Now my wife is,
and it's funny cause my wife is a big coffee drinker.
She loves us and she's got her Gorman grinder and all this stuff.
But for me now,
no way.
Uh,
what was the second question,
Tim?
Cough off.
Do you drink breakfast or Drake breakfast?
Do you eat breakfast?
You know,
I,
I found as I got older that uh,
I do best if I don't do breakfast.
I do best as a,
I used to be heavy,
heavy protein.
And then,
uh,
after I got over 50,
if I cut,
and this is me personally,
would it work for a younger athletes who are training?
I doubt it.
It's bigger engine,
need more fuel,
but for me older it's slowing down.
I find that,
uh,
not doing breakfast,
reasonable lunch.
My,
my protein sizes are so much smaller now.
Mostly vegges have a good healthy starts.
Usually it's rice or potatoes,
reasonable little protein there,
some fat at lunch way do the same at dinner,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm done.
I'm good.
I'm on.
I was amazed how much I was overeating just from habit.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Eating by the clock.
I mean,
I've noticed the same thing for myself and it's,
I've been amazed how many people I've interviewed for this podcast who are the
best at what they do,
who do not eat breakfast.
Um,
you're kidding.
Really not done.
Or it was alone in the Pavel,
you know,
his answer was coffee.
Tim.
I keep it simple.
You know,
and then,
um,
Wim Hoff,
same story.
Uh,
you look at Stan,
the general state or former General Stan Mcchrystal,
same story.
And it just goes on and on and on.
It's a good third of the men specifically.
Uh,
not sure if the female body responds as well to it,
although I'm sure there are intermittent fasting people out there who would,
who would say that,
that,
uh,
women responding in the same way,
but a very high percentage?
I'd say maybe a third of the men I've had on the podcast do not eat breakfast.
Now,
specifically,
these are men probably over the age of 45.
So I don't know.
I,
I would imagine that they're dying has probably changed over time and
interestingly enough,
if you do dig into the literature,
there is a,
or if I wanted to be a nerd,
there are data to suggest that as we get older it is possible that we absorb
protein more effectively when we have larger doses of protein less frequently.
So having them see that is interesting.
That is very interesting because I find myself every once in awhile getting a
big steak.
Yup.
You know,
once a week,
once every two weeks I'll go on,
I'll just get this massive thing of protein and then I'm,
then I'm good for a while and just marry modest.
Yeah,
so this is like Bolus of protein for like older women.
I think I saw one particular study,
it could have been an observational.
Ah,
now I get,
no,
I doubt it if they're trying to standardize the protein amount,
but it was some large amount.
It was like 70 80 grams of protein in a single feeding was absorbed better than
that same amount split over several meals in the day.
Really fascinating stuff.
What would you put on a billboard?
If you could put a billboard anywhere,
what would it just,
what's on just what's on top of my mind right now.
Yeah.
What's the top of the head?
Doesn't have to,
we're not looking for universal truth,
but just,
what's a,
I wouldn't say probiotic,
probiotic,
probiotic.
When we went,
uh,
I don't know if it had,
was a history of a,
I had to cut them out,
you know,
too much.
Margarita's uh,
you know,
and it's kind of funny now as you get older it starts creeping in more and more
and more.
But I went through a phase where it didn't matter what I ate,
didn't matter what I ate.
If I ate fat,
if I eat low fat,
if I eat veggies,
if I high protein,
terrible digestion,
just terrible digestion.
And I happened to come across something that's,
that said you,
if you have Dadadada,
Dadadada might be a probiotic issue.
And so through,
through a good buddy,
I had a laboratory grade.
Uh,
these particular ones were from Klaire labs.
He kind need prescription forum.
There are laboratory grade probiotic.
Klaire want to say it was k,
l a.
I.
R.
E.
Got it.
Okay.
No,
I'm not paid by them guys.
And there are a son of a bitch to track down cause you need a prescription for
them.
And I got get them the health provider but uh,
hooked me up in 12 hours.
And so I,
uh,
I was like,
Holy Molly,
cause I'd,
I'd,
I'd been uncomfortable or,
and in 12 hours this,
this took care of it,
uh,
contacted a buddy of mine who,
is,
you know,
great,
great at a nutrition he went over.
So,
you know,
know coach,
you should,
you should go ahead and probably take,
you know,
two,
four weeks and just really hit these probiotics hard and repopulate the guy,
you know,
years of too much Margarita was,
uh,
too much protein,
not enough Vage vegetable matter to fit,
to feed the good bacteria and sell gun night,
night and day difference.
I bet.
Simply because of that I dropped eight pounds.
Yeah,
I bet.
I'm in the,
I am currently taking a VSL three and a few other probiotics,
but one of the points you made that I think is really worth underscoring is the
vegetable matter and prebiotics.
Uh,
so providing the food that creates the environment in which bacteria that you
want to grow can grow effectively.
Whether that's through foods,
where I think,
you know,
one of the ways I had this,
uh,
biologists tell me at one point he said,
I think slow carbs going to be vindicated because you know,
the beans and lentils and so on are vilified by Paleo,
but they provide the perfect,
uh,
they provide the perfect vehicle for a prebiotic environment that can foster the
development of and growth of these areas,
bacteria and the gut.
And if not that,
you know,
if you're,
if you are a Paleo purist,
you could also consume something like foss,
you know,
flipped oligosaccharides or email it or any of these other things.
But,
um,
wow.
I had no idea that you had that experience.
Uh,
yeah,
it was,
it was shocking.
Prior to that I would've said number one supplement was lik I'm also high
vitamin D drops.
How much were you consuming,
just out of curiosity and of course the amount you'd take depends on what your
levels are dependent.
Yeah,
just,
just a little background there.
So I was at,
um,
our winter nationals seven years ago and uh,
just kind of the environment,
you know,
national team kids everywhere,
middle of the winter,
it's always in a February.
And I would just get sick,
really bad,
kind of bronchitis,
like sickness once or twice a year for Gosh,
decades.
And uh,
at one of the A's I was,
I was half dead.
And,
uh,
my assistant coach is trying to run my athletes.
He's doing his best,
but it's not going real well.
I'm,
I'm hanging under,
I'm trying to coach,
hanging over a railing and I'm visiting with Rob Wolf later that night and I'm
just like,
you know,
this,
this is ridiculous.
And Rob's the one who tagged,
he said,
coach,
you know,
it's,
it's always in the middle of other winter.
Try some,
try some vitamin D.
And I just started the liquid vitamin D.
I have not been,
if we don't count food poisoning in Hong Kong,
I,
I've not been sick sense.
Yeah.
And that,
and that's quite a swing,
you know,
once or twice pretty serious per year to nothing for seven.
And the only thing that changed in that time was that was the vitamin D.
So I,
I am,
I'm,
you know,
I'm pretty,
pretty
practical.
If that was the one variable I changed now as a result,
while boom,
that's,
that's the doorstep I budded at.
What to do you have a particular brand that you use for that?
I want to say I,
I've looked at it as so many years.
I just cannot pick it up off the shelf.
And I want to say it was biotest perhaps.
Got It.
And so I can't,
I can't swear about other ones.
I just know I've always used that particular one.
I've done,
gosh,
all kinds of different protocols from one or two drops a day.
It's like,
it's like a runny Elmers glue for those who haven't had it.
Uh,
yeah.
It's the taste isn't,
you know,
anything to get upset at all.
My daughters,
when they were young,
disagree,
they say Jose,
who was the worst thing about it?
It's,
it's not bad at all.
Uh,
we've done a daily,
a few drops all the way up to once or twice a week with a eight to 10 drops,
you know,
and just mix it up.
It just seems like,
you know,
as long as you're consistent,
it almost doesn't matter.
Yes.
I'm guessing each of those drops is probably an ICU and one internationally,
but ah,
gosh,
it seems like,
um,
then I'm,
I'm tied to a computer right now.
Right.
I'd go,
I'd go grab it for you.
It seemed like the dosage is surprisingly high in each drop and you know,
and I'm,
I'm a big fan,
especially as you get older,
you've got to go get blood work and anything else is guessing.
Yeah.
You need to get blood work,
period.
I mean,
if you get your choice,
if you get your car checked out more often than you get your blood work done,
then you need to rearrange your priorities.
Uh,
so last,
uh,
last question and this is where I'd like you to certainly,
among other things to point people to where they can learn more about you and
gymnastic bodies.
But,
uh,
what's,
what ask or request would you have for my audience?
For the people listening?
I'm not understanding the question.
So the question there actually kind of two separate things.
So one is outside of gymnastics,
a gymnastic bodies and the work that you're up to and pointing people to that,
do you have any ask or request for the people listening?
I mean,
they're going to be hundreds of thousands at the very least in the first week,
maybe millions of people listening to this.
What would you like them to think on,
do or consider?
Oh,
okay.
Very good.
Actually.
I love that question.
I would like them to consider two things.
I would like them to consider where's the fire?
Where's the fire?
Where's wars?
The rush?
Where's the rational?
Why are they trying to accomplish everything?
Their current goals yesterday?
Why?
Why not slow down a little bit.
Not saying not to work hard,
but why don't we just slow down a little bit,
little more reasonable pace,
some more consistency so that,
that,
that would be number one ask.
And then second one is mobility.
Whether it's my material,
when it's just the stuff that Tim posts for you,
whether it's someone else's material and um,
it's,
it's fine with me guys,
but we've,
we've got to get those bodies moving.
We've to get natural range
of motion back again,
that,
that alone,
if we did the hierarchy,
what will increase quality of life?
The fastest for them is going to be mobility first,
then core,
then you know,
your more conventional strength,
your arms,
your shoulders,
Yada,
Yada.
And where can people find you online,
on social media,
et Cetera.
W W what would you recommend as a next step for somebody who's never done
gymnastics?
Anything who wants to dip their toe in the water?
Uh,
first sang goto gymnastic bodies.
Dot.
Come on now.
We are,
we are putting a,
we have a special landing page for your,
for your listeners,
Tim,
with a nice discount forum.
But we have a nice introductory program that's just gymnastic bodies,
Gui,
s.com/tim and we've got,
we've got a nice discount,
therefore you for a nice intro program.
Uh,
it's about a 24 day program,
a gentle introduction to kind of the language we speak,
get started on some mobility,
some great follow along videos forum,
you know,
kind of hold their hand,
make sure they get started off on the right foot.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's been a tremendous learning experience for me so far.
It's only been,
I mean really a handful of weeks that we've been digging into this deeply,
although we had some prep time and talking about it prior to that.
Uh,
and uh,
definitely guys,
if you are like,
ah,
you know,
I'm so busy,
I'm doing this,
that and the other thing,
take a look at the program.
But at the very least,
follow a gymnastic potties on Instagram.
And every time you see a video from a student,
uh,
who seems to throw one of your excuses at the window,
like pick a take a second.
I just admire what someone has done from scratch.
Like Matt who you mentioned who started in his late forties,
uh,
awesome.
Like one by one.
If you just watch that and straight on account for a week,
you'll run out of excuses a very,
very,
very quickly.
Uh,
what about,
uh,
elsewhere on social media?
Is there any,
well,
where else people can see how do you
are a Facebook page is gymnastic bodies.com.
Little,
a little more proper there.
Uh,
my personal page,
Christopher Sommer,
s o m m e r,
m,
a little more,
no rules there.
And I'm not,
I'm not insane,
but my,
my interests are wide ranging.
So if you come to my page,
you a,
you're taking your chances what I'm going to torture you with that day.
So it might be conditioning or it might be,
you know what I think such,
such as Kik,
gas,
and I like it.
So you're going to like it too.
And you do throw up some,
some ridiculous in the best way possible videos of just monsters doing some
absurd,
absurd stuff.
I mean,
the,
who's the Gent you sent me?
You encouraged me to check this out.
This guy who was going from,
you're trying to explain the,
uh,
let me get this right.
I want to say plate planches that I was doing while back,
which you're kind of like a front raise holding onto a plate with the shoulders.
Super,
super protracted and the massive,
a posterior pelvic tilt I sent,
I sent you that clip of a world champ on rings.
It was,
it might've been,
I think you said you sent me of one of Van Gelder on rings and then he sent me
one of this guy on parallel bars going forward.
Hand Gelder again.
Okay.
Going from the handstand to the,
uh,
the,
the straight body plant.
Oh Holy God.
We do it.
We do it with 10 or 25 pounds.
He was doing it with full body way.
Oh my God.
How do you,
how do you spell van Gelder you're a hearing so much Uri.
A van.
Gelder I think he's from Netherlands,
if I'm remembering right.
Former world champ,
a v a n space g.
E l d e r,
just a monster.
Oh my God.
Oh such.
So just Raisie strong and not,
I mean it doesn't look like a small guy either.
I mean,
Scott,
he's a big boy.
He's got like two people's back.
He has got a wide back.
It's a people's check that out and I'll link to everything in the show notes.
A well coach,
thank you so much for the time.
Uh,
I know it's precious and I uh,
I think people will get a real kick out of this and we crammed a lot into the
talk.
So he did talk a lot.
It was good.
So I look forward to chatting again soon,
which I'm sure we will do.
And to everybody listening,
you can find all of the links to everything that I can track down that my team
can track down a related to all the topics we covered,
uh,
links to coach everywhere,
gymnastic bodies,
everywhere in the show notes.
A,
that'll just be@fourhourworkweek.com.
Forward Slash podcast all spelled out for our work week.com forward slash
podcast and as always,
and until next time.
Thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very
next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by exo protein.
It's one of the startups that I work with.
I love what they do.
These guys are making protein bars using crickets,
protein powder,
and before you screw your face up and look disgusted,
I bet they taste better than any protein bar you've ever had before.
I devour these bars after lifting sessions.
I take them with me on the road.
The recipes were developed by a three Michelin Star Chef,
former head of r and d at the fat duck,
which was ranked the number one restaurant in the world during his tenure.
The bars are paleo friendly,
no gluten,
no grains,
no soy,
no dairy,
et cetera.
They are high in protein and flavor and extremely unique and they do not pop
your glycemic response up,
oddly enough,
and you can look that up on line,
uh,
to,
to see some stories on that.
Ferran Stein,
that's the journalist who looked at it on top of all that.
They are less processed than nearly all protein bars.
You'll be able to find.
This is your chance to see what the hype is about.
The founders were just on the Forbes 30 under 30 list and they are offering a
deep discount to Tim Ferriss show listeners.
If you go to exo protein.com forward slash Tim,
that's e x o protein.com forward slash Tim today,
you can try a sampler pack with all of their most popular flavors for less than
10 bucks.
That's extra protein.com forward slash Tim and I would recommend doing it
relatively fast and that's not a bs scarcity thing.
They're startup with limited inventory and the side all the time.
That is what happened last time I mentioned that,
so check it out.
EXO,
protein.com forward slash
yep,
so does brought to you by headspace.
More than 80% of the people I have interviewed,
world class performers across the military,
entertainment,
sports and beyond all have some type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help you.
This change comes through guided meditation and headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple,
so what I recommend is that you take this practice meditation,
which is rooted in thousands of years of tradition,
supported by thousands of scientific studies and try it for 10 minutes a day for
10 days.
That's all you need to do.
You could also check out the founder,
Andy Puddicombe,
a ted talk,
which has more than 5.5 million views.
His last name is Pud,
Do you want to look that up?
But otherwise,
download the free headspace APP.
I have it on my phone and begin their take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation.
Completely free.
10 minutes a day.
That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash.
Tim,
just go to headspace.com forward slash Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.